Boom,
and we're live.
Oh,
when you go in Australia or you move in
there,
I'd never been,
I'd never,
never been.
I never would lead.
You love it.
That's what they say,
man.
I get a lot of Australians come to the
store and I'm going to perform at the
cellar.
A lot of Australian,
so I go fly over here to see comedy.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
They take comedy vacations.
It's super common.
You ever see like a hot dog spot and it
says like world famous.
How does it feel?
Like when I talked to an Australian,
I can say I'm world famous,
but I've never been over there.
Well I think a lot of them come over
here just to like,
ah,
fuck it.
Let's go to Australia and get a fucking
fly over to Los Angeles and see what
it's like over there.
They've got more people in their state.
Then we have in our entire country,
there's more people in the greater la
area then in the entire,
the entirety.
What's that feel like?
You know?
And they're as big as the United States.
Yeah.
It's huge.
Yeah,
it's huge.
So it's the size of can tick the tick
contiguous United States.
I think the lower 48 I don't think it's
the lasting included,
but it has less people than in Los
Angeles.
I learned that lower 48 term when I was
in Alaska.
I didn't even know that.
Yeah,
they barely or matter.
it was crazy.
You look at it,
you're like,
what?
How is this up here?
This is America too.
Huh?
How'd Y'all get in
lower?
48 yeah.
I used to have a joke about Sarah Pale
and I'm like,
that's a fruit frozen Puerto Rico.
That's what that is.
It's so not America.
That's barely America is Larry.
Those people are cool as fuck though.
Yeah man.
I loved it.
Everything was rustic.
That was the word for like,
it was a bug on my spoon,
man.
They got it's rustic.
Everbank banging on things.
I became a nerd to us.
I like the Aurora borealis night.
It was beautiful.
It was up close and whales breaching
Resurrection Bay I think is where I
went.
It was fun.
I loved it.
I went in April so it wasn't too cold,
but it was still cold as shit.
Yeah,
it's,
it's weird up there because the people
are just,
they're so accustomed to like the trials
and tribulations of nature.
They feel like they're harder.
Your folk.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
Know what I mean.
Definitely.
They're not consumed with like the stuff
that we are about it with and they,
everybody has a plane.
Like every other person had a plane in
their backyard.
Bush plane
to this Po.
This place is going crazy.
We lost garrison keillor and Matt went
down.
That's what they get crazy.
I got say,
man,
there's an Keelan.
Let me,
let me let them low talking.
Dude's still a slow talking.
He'll come to lake wobegon.
Yeah,
the whispery public broadcast radio
could use your donations.
We love bringing you quality content
when it comes to the price.
Yeah,
but the first guy to go down was that
John Ghomeshi guy who was at the NBR
president,
the CBC guy.
That was bitches.
Oh,
who was the mushroom?
That's the dude.
He was like,
Mr. Calm and progressive and I'm a
feminist.
I don't trust it.
I call myself a feminist ladies.
You can listen.
You can not trust,
I'm not the best human being in the
world,
but I swear to God,
what you see is what you get.
Yeah.
All right.
You gotta be careful with these fucking
male feminists that is just,
that is a sneaky ploy to get pussy.
What was that one?
Who Was it?
Was it,
uh,
Eric Weinstein that was telling us about
a particular type of cuddle fish that
pretends to be a female so he can get in
close with the males because the males
don't recognize him as being a threat.
What was it?
Sneaky sneaker male.
Like a sneaker male.
Hilarious.
Operate like underneath the large cuddle
fish and with all the females and bangs
on me getting on the sneak tip.
That's the dude.
It's like,
I understand you.
Yeah.
Is that on his dope sneaker?
Male cuddle fish of Thailand?
Yeah.
So it literally is like a transgender
cuddle fish tends to be a woman,
but really it's just trying to get some
pussy.
That's it.
And it hit strategy is not to be the
big,
you know,
uh,
ever present dominant male but instead
just slip around just the girls.
That's like,
that's like the one straight dude and a
ballet zone and he's like,
the women complained to me about all the
other guys and then I ended up smashing
them all like the one straight dude in a
church choir.
You know when you see those guys who
they really are,
when one of the ballerinas boyfriends
show up straight dudes bitchy to them.
Oh
fuck my girl.
You been trying to know you've got this
whole thing cultivated.
Your watering it all,
putting it fertilize,
you send it all that shit moves.
She gets the bills,
get calendar.
You got your fake books,
you're pretending to read that you leave
out a lot of shit that we do.
Everybody has a mood.
It was garrison keillor's.
He was,
he was probably to,
you know,
just the intellect man.
He was a professor.
He was the historial crush.
Right?
Lake wobegon.
He created this whole world to do
Minnesota.
It was prince and this and garrison
keillor.
Yeah.
So look at him.
Look at that dude.
Oh Dude was slinging Dick.
Oh,
tear Gershon character in the
accusations.
I Dunno thing.
No Man.
All chick has to do with hate you.
That's what scary.
Yeah.
And then you're guilty.
The bucket is so wide.
It's like it's the Weinstein of it all
and then it's,
I don't know,
an hour of it all.
I don't know what Matt did.
But yeah,
I don't know what he did either.
But then there's like the Louis C K
angle where he doesn't even touch it.
He just jerked off in front of you like
the fuck.
Like my boys say though,
he's like,
you don't know what it's like to have a
dick
because you think about it like who?
Like who would put everything in peril
to just circle off in front of someone.
Like you know this is going to come back
on it.
Yes.
So it has to be something,
something which your Dick that makes you
go,
I have to do this.
I've been saying this for awhile.
I think it's one of the things that like
makes people funny too,
is that ridiculous way of viewing the
world.
You just chaotic,
impulsive,
nutty Shit.
And the next thing you know and you're
like,
can I drop off in front of you?
You're like,
what?
You push the limits?
And she started,
let me see how ridiculous I can be.
Yeah.
You want to see what people's lines are
and if I didn't work,
it might've worked for somebody.
Yeah.
That whip it out.
Like the whipping your dick out thing.
Like I know dudes that people tried to
get me to do that in college.
They were like,
Yo,
you should just pull your dick out.
And I'm like,
that works.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I never had the courage to just pull my
dick out in front of a girl.
But I know cats,
they're doing it all the time.
But when it does work,
like Holy Shit,
I got to figure out what the rhythm is.
What's the beets?
The beets?
Is it a movie first is,
there's some times where it can work and
you're like,
what?
How does that,
how's that possible?
But then other times where you would
pull your dick out and grow and be like,
what the fuck?
I'm sorry Jesus,
what did I do?
If you're Jesus,
you can't bat baseball averages,
which a nick polo game because he died,
it's a low acid,
low average,
it's a low average and now come back and
hit that one out of a hundred
it was worth it until the day man,
the off 99 are coming out and if you
have like a freak girlfriend,
yeah,
like when you're in high school or
something like that and then just ruins
your perception.
You know what else fucks it not to do is
up the Strip club.
They hang out there so they have this
false reality of what you know,
Oh yeah,
woman is this.
And then when they go out and just try
to talk to a regular woman and like,
well you got to get to know me first.
I'm like,
fuck you bitch.
They don't even know how to do that.
But it was also,
you're just getting used to dealing with
freaks.
You're dealing with freaks all the time.
They have a different,
different parameters.
Not like the lady in the office that
handles accounting and I take out on
her.
No,
but that is nice when you meet a woman,
you has agency over her body and knows
what she likes.
That could fuck you up when you go and
you dating,
dealing with somebody that's not that
free.
Yeah.
That could be a,
that's a problem where we're girls just,
they're not freeze the right word.
Right.
They're not relaxed enough or
comfortable enough in their own skin or
nothing.
Know what they like and just can tell
you and you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's when you have to decide if
you already liker,
because if you do like focus on her and,
and bring that out over and you don't
like her,
it's going to be hard to get all of
that.
Yeah.
That's a problem.
I did it a girl once a long time ago,
like way back in the day and was in and
I went to my twenties and I loved having
sex with her,
but I hate and hanging out with us.
I know,
man.
It's that.
It's that how'd,
how'd you,
how'd you try to like I'm ghoster when
you,
when she got mad at me,
that's what they always did.
They always want them getting mad at me.
They just get mad at you just so you're
not doing what they want you to do and
you're not marrying them.
You got this,
you know that you're not,
oh man,
that crazy.
Don't think about that.
You got what you wanted and then you had
to sit through that moment of her being
upset with,
you knew what was coming,
but you already got what you wanted.
He's know what I'm saying.
The part of her behavior was like a game
to try to get me in,
you know,
like part of her freak shit.
Yeah.
It was just like,
she knew that that's what I want from
her,
you know?
So she would act like the free kids
don't care deck right here.
Yeah,
me too.
Yeah.
The quote in the movie theater,
I'll suck your Dick.
Right?
Whoa.
Jesus.
Right.
I don't know what's on the menu,
but I'll take it and then when you go,
all right,
I'm good.
Yeah,
like watts.
How could you exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Like some part of like that behavior.
It's like they know that other girls
don't behave like that.
If they just turn this shit up to nine,
like Whoa,
it's dope.
And then you think about them all the
time and it gets exciting.
Then after she's mad at you,
then that's when I would date her.
No,
dig sucks in the more angry fuck you on
him.
Like movies.
I like to move forward.
How come you don't like,
who does it?
Like movies you had,
a friend of mine was talking to me about
this,
about uh,
like a girl that has been like real open
about all the different gods she fucked
and all that.
And now she's going to settle down.
But I was promiscuous in the past and
I'm not doing that anymore.
And the guy's like,
hey,
wait a minute.
Wait,
I missed it.
I missed.
Yeah.
Borealis the worst.
Yes.
It could have been here in April.
I would have saw the lights in the sky.
Yes.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
I hate born again,
virgin.
I get it though.
I ain't doing it no more til I get
married.
It's like you got,
you got two kids like you.
Have you used to fuck.
It's my turn.
It's my turn know to had to do to get in
this seat.
Just let people be who they are,
man.
When you see that,
the thing is like this is what men do
and with also what women do.
We tried to change the person we're with
like,
oh,
this dude doesn't dress good,
but I just get him the right clothes.
Just teach him how to groom his hair,
you know?
Get them to wear more stylish things.
Yeah.
They'll just start to change you.
When you started looking better,
you confidence gets up.
He was like,
why am I with you?
I want to get with her now.
I had a buddy of mine who would get
girls and get them to go on a diet.
He would date cute girls that were like
a little chubby and then take it to the
gym,
added value.
And I was like,
what are you doing?
He's like,
no,
this way.
Like they really like you.
You get them and then you can make them
hot and,
but that's a lot of work.
It's chaos.
You can't,
I mean it might work,
but it's like the whip,
the Dick out thing.
One out of a hundred it's going to work.
The other girl is going to be hiding
candy.
Like how can we not losing any weight
or the dude,
you know,
a girl takes a chubby dude and bring
them to the gym all the time.
You can't make a chubby like a fitness
freak.
It's like people are who they are.
They are who they are,
who they are.
Man,
I'm a,
but I am,
I'm trying to get to lose some weight.
Are you?
I'm doing,
I'm trying to intermittent fasting.
I do that.
I mess with that.
Yeah,
I do that every night.
Oh,
word.
Yeah.
Walks up on vacation.
I can't five pounds,
even though I worked out every day on
vacation every day,
but I drank and ate everything.
I gained five pounds a week.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
Wow.
Yeah.
So I just went off.
How many hours do you go?
What are you an 1820,
14,
14.
Yeah,
that's probably what I'm doing,
I think.
Yeah,
I do a 10:00 PM at night and you know,
I'll do 10:00 PM at night and then um,
or 8:00 PM at night rather than an
antennae m in the morning.
Oh.
So it's not bad.
So I'm done eating everything.
No more food after 8:00 PM at night and
then,
uh,
10:00 AM in the morning and it started
eating.
Oh that's dope.
It's easy.
All right.
Yeah.
Just,
you know what man,
it's like that feeling when you come
home from the store though and you're
like,
damn,
I like to eat something.
You know,
but you guys got to pass that up and
then we know what else I got to pass up
having something to drink at night,
like glass of water or something like
that.
Cause it's always like four in the
morning.
God Damn it.
Yeah,
they're not that good sleep.
Get up,
you got to Piss,
you go back to bed again.
But in a couple of nights I've been
fucking good and discipline or after a
certain time,
no liquids and their sleep like a baby
all through the night.
Wake up at night you did something.
And the other thing I do now is that we
work out in the morning.
Yeah,
that's what I've been doing.
Work out in the morning before I eat.
I think I figured it out.
So I think I figured out how I'm going
to do it.
How are you going to do it?
I try to burn.
I started wearing a heart rate monitor
finally.
Oh.
And I tried to burn a thousand calories
in my workout.
That's what I tried to get to.
That's a lot.
Yes,
a lot.
And so,
but if I can get to the thousand,
then if I try to,
if I eat 1800 calories that whole day,
then that 800 for sure.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what I'm trying.
I'm one day three day three is do you
go,
do you follow a specific type of diet?
Are you eating specific foods?
Well,
I mean I,
I try to um,
be more on the plant base tip,
but I'm not,
I'm not a Vegan because I will let them
and all that stuff.
I'm not,
and I think Vegan is like,
I love what it represents,
but I think their marketing,
that's not the best word people are
running from that term.
So I just like,
well people run it from comments.
There's a lot of people that are Vegan,
they're just can't.
So some lecture on yesterday and you
know what?
He does know the famous power lifter,
very motivational guy.
But that dude right there,
he was saying that he,
he,
he doesn't even say he's Vegan anymore
because people were so goddamn military.
I'm not doing this for the animals.
I'm doing this shit from my health.
Right.
But if you say that people got mad at
him,
so he's like,
I just say I eat vegan most of the time.
Yeah.
That's most of the time.
That's what he says.
I get it.
But the vegans that are good people that
are just doing it because they care and
they're kind,
they get a bum rap because of all the
psychos and those cycles almost always
have like Vegan in their name.
Like vegan warrior early.
Yeah,
Vegan earth goddess.
Vegan first.
But you know,
it's funny if Vegan is last,
they tend to be cooler like this way.
It's like it's,
I'm this person and then Vegan,
like my man Epi,
Vegan,
he loves your show.
I'm going to do,
I'm going to do a segment when he comes
to town and uh,
okay.
I like that cat.
He's a cool,
I had a lot of vegans.
Yeah,
but I'm mocked.
I'm like,
I'm mocking myself.
I mark myself.
How the fuck am I not going to mock?
My wife isn't Vegan and try to,
but she'll eat stuff that I'm making
some tough.
She'll play kate.
Me.
I did.
I took a huge loss on Thanksgiving
though.
I made two pies.
I like to cook and stuff.
So I made to a sweet potato pies,
one with one with milk and butter and
all the stuff that you had growing up.
Boom.
And I did that and then I made one vegan
one just to see what would a,
what people would like.
And Man,
it was just one slight sticking out of
the Vegan
was sad slice and everybody was like,
man,
come on.
And they,
but they tore the other pile.
I of course
had to wrap it up and take it back home
with,
he was still in the fridge.
What's in the Vegan One?
So instead of eggs you make a flax seed
eggs.
So your pod got freckles.
I know that.
I don't want no freckles on my got damp
odd but,
but then it's everything else.
It's the same.
Uh,
and instead of,
I'm using half and half,
you use like,
um,
use a,
it'd be like almond milk mixed with like
coconut milk.
That's all right.
And then you do a,
and then,
but at the same all sugar flour,
all that's the same.
And no eggs,
no eggs,
but eggs.
You can't taste eggs,
eat them.
It's just exit is a binding agent.
It just holds it together.
When I was in Hawaii last week,
we made Gnocchi.
What's that?
We took a class.
It's a potato pasta.
They were talking about that at the
store.
I've never had that.
Which delicious.
Is that good?
Yeah,
it's good.
It makes good Gnocchi though because
everyone,
everyone's eye contact.
Divert.
Like I said,
who makes good nobody?
They're like,
man,
you out here.
It's like,
I want,
I want to taste it like what is this?
It's an Italian food.
You just got to go to a good Italian
restaurant and they make the number.
All right.
Yeah.
Just find a good Italian place that has
pasta and no time.
No keep.
Most likely,
and it's not spelled and Okai.
It's a gene is a gene.
From there.
I've always,
when you open the menu and you know,
I was like,
you know fucking with that like I
like lamb chops.
Then Nokia like suck none of my meals to
track.
It's probably been sitting there my
whole life.
Going to a fancy Italian restaurants and
just never,
it's an interesting pasta because it's a
pasta made with like they make it with
potatoes,
they boiled potatoes and they smash them
down and then they um,
they get it to a certain consistency
that it off.
And
then they add certain amount of flour.
Like we did the whole thing.
We chopped it up,
we pressed it into your roll it roll the
flower out until I like a little tube.
Then you cut little sections of it and
you make your Gnocchi with the sections
and do you have to then be baked that or
do you yeah,
they boil it,
boil it,
boil.
I think.
I didn't watch them do it and I'm pretty
sure they boil it though.
Make it eel sauce and then that's
awesome.
We got a bunch of different sauces.
We though the chef cooked it with three
different sauces.
He cooked it with uh,
a Bolognese sauce.
He cooked it with a,
um,
uh,
it was like a cheese sauce with,
with uh,
walnuts,
like a walnut.
I forget what kind of cheese.
And then there was another one,
one other sock.
A pesto.
I love.
I make fresh cut pesto.
Yeah,
it was good man.
it's really good.
Yeah man.
I just,
I think if you just cut out bread and
then cut out pasta,
those are the two big ones.
Just cut that shit.
Gnocchi.
Pasta dough.
Yeah,
but that's potato pasta.
So that's different.
It's different.
Yeah.
It's not as good for you as like some
things,
but I don't think it's nearly as bad for
you as grain brain.
I think green is just the terrible.
Have you gotten through,
I haven't gotten through night.
That dude's book,
wheat belly belly?
No,
I haven't watched the documentary on the
plane coming back from Hawaii about
wheat.
Let me see the fucking name of it is,
but it was a,
it was a trip and it was all talking
about the roundup chemicals that they
spray on.
There it is.
And they were talking about how people
say,
well,
it only affects bacteria.
And they were saying,
yeah,
but you have bacteria in your fucking
gut,
right?
Yeah.
What's,
what's with wheat?
Uh,
that's the,
uh,
the name of the documentary and it's,
it's not good.
I tried watching it.
That dude was talking.
I was just,
I couldn't,
I was all right man.
I was falling as droning on.
And that's the problem with all those
academics.
Like to be the type of person that could
sit down and do that kind of research.
Painstaking time consuming research
boring is five and you need those
people,
man.
Those people are the only ones that are
going to do it.
You're not going to do it.
I'm not going to do it.
No.
I know.
We need those people tests and then just
explaining to you the dangers of complex
glutens group.
Yeah,
man.
So yeah,
that's,
that's my goal.
So I'll check back in with you and like
six weeks to see if I'm away.
I need them three days in feeling strong
though.
Right?
I'm calm,
I'm talking about it publicly.
I'm usually really private about what
I'm doing.
Yeah.
So I think talking about it publicly is
important.
Hey man,
once you,
once you get it out there,
yeah.
Once you get over 40 I feel like,
I feel like you can eat whatever you
want until you're 40 because you only
get one in testing.
So then you have to start your body
loses enzymes that will break it down as
vigorously.
Cause I have a son now and I watch my
son,
my son eat anything and he's,
his energy is high,
you know,
and all of that.
But when you get older you lose some of
those enzymes.
I feel like enzymes are like government
workers.
Like you eat a steak.
They're like,
who's going to get that?
I mean getting that shit for 40 years.
Anybody,
somebody else,
we're going to get there.
And so then it sits in the city plus
your sons growing mustaches,
fondness for calories,
just turning them off.
He's starting to speak sign language
now.
Like just the little things,
you know,
he knows more and we give them some food
and we taught him more and he just
looked at us like we were silly.
And then like a couple of hours later
he's like,
am I bad?
Brang it.
You told me this when it's not working.
I'm doing it well in the beginning they
say sign language is a really good thing
to teach kids cause they can't really
formulate the words yet.
The mouth.
That's why they get frustrated.
They start crying because I can't tell
you what they want,
but they know what they want.
It's amazing.
They don't know a language yet.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
And he would,
he's a huge prince fan.
Yeah.
I love playing records.
And so my wife got me a dope record
player for Christmas and uh,
we play Prince's purple rain on the air
and if I play anything else,
he,
and you know,
he just wants prints really.
And I,
and I'll go,
you want,
you want to hear some music with dinner?
And he'll,
he'll run to the record player and he'll
start China.
How old is he?
He's 14 months.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so like he understands things like
I'd be like,
get the ball and he'll get it and then
we'll play.
But I could see him wanting to say it.
Occasionally he'll sit and just stop
mocking me.
I'll say get the boy.
But I like,
I could see him trying to just
literally just start saying,
trying to say what I just said in the
same rhythm.
Bang.
He starts talking to you.
That's [inaudible] wait man.
I have little conversations with my kids
while I'm talking to them.
I'm talking to them about what we're
talking about,
but most of my brain is like,
I can't believe you can talk.
Yeah,
I know.
I can't believe you're a person and
we're,
we're uh,
you're a seven year old person and we're
exploring the world together with
having,
talking about stuff.
And my kids are way too aggressive with
me physically though,
especially my littlest one.
But my seventh girl,
all girls,
man,
my seven year old,
she fucking tackles me all the time,
just full on charge.
Like I'm indestructible when she takes
mma.
So she will slam into me,
grab a single leg thrower's shoulder
into me.
If I plopped down on the bed,
she gets on top of me,
she drops on top of me and amount,
she'll start punching my stomach.
She thinks it's hilarious because I'm
like a toy.
She feels like she could just beat on me
cause I can just carry her and pick her
up all the time.
I put her on my shoulders and she was
like,
this mother fucker could just carry me.
I can't even can't even hurt him.
Right.
Wail on him.
That's so funny.
It's hilarious man.
She's so aggressive,
man.
I want my son to know how to do all that
stuff.
Oh yeah.
Get them involved early then it'll be,
it'll be a normal part of life so that
way,
like bullies and conflict,
it won't bother them because I know how
to fight.
I had to make bullies laugh.
You're a big dude.
Big Dude.
Yeah,
but I've got a short torso,
so like
five,
eight sitting down when I used to,
I grew up in Maryland,
so I used to,
you know,
we had public transit
and stuff,
so whenever I would be on public transit
I would always see the dude's like,
Yo,
we got one and then I will have to stand
up.
They were like,
oh nevermind.
But yeah,
my height saved me a lot and that's
funny.
He helped me a lot to being funny as the
good ones.
Like,
Oh,
this guy's not trying to be dominant and
she wants to be the silly dude.
Yeah.
Okay.
We like you.
You know what?
I used to do two though.
Uh,
I only,
I only told,
I'm Collin Quinn,
this story.
Oh,
when I grew up in these apartments,
pembrook apartments in Prince George's
county,
Maryland,
there was his mum bullied,
uh,
who would steal people's bikes and shit
and he would start fights or whatever.
And so I had,
I played sports,
I,
you know,
so one of my trophies broke and my mom
took me to some place to fix it.
And I did not know that there was a
place that existed when you,
I just thought trophies appeared,
you know,
I mean,
as a kid you just get a shot.
Right.
So when I saw this was the spot,
what I used to do because I was saving
my allowance and I would go to the
trophy spot and buy like a karate
trophy,
just walk around the neighborhood just
long enough for this one dude to see me
who I knew would be like the town crier.
And I would always act embarrassed about
it.
Like,
Oh,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And that's how we talk.
We say young and stuff.
I mean,
my mother got me taking karate and shit.
I'm wanting to steal to,
oh,
you,
you're going to cry.
You Nice like that.
Don't tell nobody man,
I ain't gonna say shit.
And then I would see it.
So then,
uh,
and then like,
you know,
a couple of months ago by,
I go by and by a little bigger town,
dude never mess with me.
He never mess.
Thank God.
No one was like,
oh,
I can fight.
But I,
you know what I'm saying?
But it was like the word got out enough
because nobody knew karate.
I'm saying like if you heard the dude
did karate,
that was enough.
Like,
you didn't want to get embarrassed.
So he gave me like free passage to do
various be be my corny self,
be out,
you know.
Thank you very clever way of handling
it.
Because what I did when I saw that store
I was like,
and that's the piece of home,
they were like five bucks,
70 bucks,
big bucks and hour girl put it on.
And then so I was acting at an early
age.
There's all that shit.
Like just planning.
I said I know what he going to be.
You know,
as soon as he saw me I'd go back in the
house.
I didn't want like a big,
you know what I mean?
That's very clever.
Like psychologically when the right guy
that couldn't keep his mouth shut.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh he's that guy.
You know who that guy is.
Yeah.
And He,
and he was so funny too cause um,
I bet he works for tmz now.
Probably if he,
if,
if he got out,
if I'm right,
because that was in our neighborhood.
It was,
people were afraid to dream out loud.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I wanted to be a comedian since I was
nine,
but I ain't tell nobody because I saw
somebody else and say,
I want to be here.
What?
Whatever man you ain't going to do.
You can't say shit.
So funny how people want to squash
dreams.
Yeah.
Because it's their fear.
But you don't realize that till you're
older.
Right.
There's their fear to,
they're pushing on you.
Yeah.
And so they and they own way.
They think they're helping you.
Right.
They give you a dose of reality.
Yeah.
Like,
and you go,
you in Boston,
so you,
you had this too.
A lot of people yell at you helpful
Shit.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like it was like a yelling community.
Like don't do that.
Does it?
You know?
So always had like,
uh,
people always yet,
oh,
I washed the street,
you know,
like they will be like really
emotionally charged like gang street to
go,
you know,
as opposed to,
hey man,
it was never calm.
Everything was,
you were always yelled at.
It was like a yacht.
A lot of yelling.
Nowhere.
I founded the weirdest as I worked as a
limo driver once and uh,
there's this guy that worked in the
dispatch and this guy was just like a
real bitter dude and he wasn't that much
older than me.
I was 21 and he was probably like 26 or
27 but he had given up and he was a
dispatch guy and I worked all day.
I had an eight hour shift and then after
I did the eight hour shift and like,
hey man,
I got to go,
I've got a show tonight.
Yeah.
And he's like,
a lot of guys here work 12 hours.
Dego that's great.
I go,
but I did my eight hours.
I'm going,
yeah.
And they're like,
well we need some airport pickups.
I'm like,
I did eight hours.
I go,
I'm not working more than eight hours a
day for you guys.
Like this is like a part time job.
I work eight hours a day,
I'm gone.
This motherfucker called the place where
I was supposed to be performing to find
out if I was there and something
happened and I got switched to another
place.
Like the book name said,
Hey,
why don't you work at this place
instead?
And so I went to north Texas and he's
like,
yeah.
He goes,
you weren't at that fucking place.
You said you were last night.
Well,
I was like,
first of all,
dude,
I'm done working right.
I'm done.
I go,
second of all,
they switched me.
The booking agents call this other
place.
I go call the other place.
I'll wait and we're just looking at each
other and like,
this guy just doesn't want dreams.
Yes.
He's like,
yeah,
you're out there doing comedy.
You can be making me real money here.
It's real money.
How you not see,
this is the thing.
They were pointed to this one dude,
there was this old dude who worked there
and I remember he was this big fat guy
who had a cadillac and that was the
thing they were saying,
you know John over here,
he works,
it doesn't bust his ass be,
he works about 60 hours a week and he,
he's got a beautiful cadillac and then
this cadillac and he's just sitting in
there.
It was like,
wow,
John's got a cadillac.
He was like probably in his like late
forties fat dude just could tell you
where the best veal Scallopini is.
Huh?
It was just knew where the food is
because he just sat in his car all day
driving around and then I remember
thinking like this poor fuck,
like John makes about $60,000 a year.
He'll have to bust his ass.
It's a good living.
And they would point to him,
look at his Cadillac and we were all,
I was like,
Whoa,
this is prison.
This guy's working 16 hours a day.
Like,
what the fuck is going on here man?
I can't live like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah man.
You got that.
You got to dream bigger than that.
I mean,
one of my boys,
he,
he's doing really well.
He could always sing.
So I think we used to always have little
singing groups and uh,
and we have,
this is a local music called Gogo music.
Go go music.
Yeah.
It's like a lot of percussion and horns
and like so cool.
It was to where it's a,
it's really local in the DC,
Maryland,
Virginia area.
But you've heard Gogo like,
um,
it's,
it's splashed.
It has some national hits like doing the
but is a gogo song doing,
how about my experience on limited?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah that,
so in the 70s,
uh,
they used to be music programs in all
the schools.
So all these cats were coming out
learning like instrumentation,
composition,
like all this stuff.
But like an our era,
they cut that.
So,
but,
but google bands,
they still played like live music.
So we would all try to form,
go,
go groups,
but we couldn't read music.
So we would be like,
your party is boot buck a buck a ball
boy.
That's how he would talk to each other.
You want the horn,
you played fun.
We didn't know notes or anything,
but we would always like try to do that
or will be in a little singing group or
something like that.
And one cat cussing so well,
and I just remember when my mom,
we moved away when I was 13.
I remember hoping that he would keep
singing years later.
I'm asleep on my couch,
man.
And I love music videos.
So I had it playing and I heard a
familiar voice in,
I wake up,
it was him.
Wow.
Started crying on my couch.
TV.
Yeah.
He made that out.
He,
yeah,
he's fantastic.
And He's,
he got nominated for a grammy,
uh,
two years ago.
Wow.
Yeah.
His name's,
uh,
boots,
black boots.
His name's Alford.
Antonio Dunkin.
He went,
uh,
he called black bu and that's what he
calls himself.
He and he calls himself boot black
boots,
a professional one.
I mean,
we were,
he was like my brother growing up.
Like he's,
I'm an only child,
but he,
uh,
his real name is Alpha,
but he,
so this is how we met.
Like probably,
I don't know how old I was,
but it was a knock on my door.
Saturday morning cartoons.
That's him.
That's how I,
yeah.
And so then a mambo sauce is the name
of,
uh,
Google ban.
He was in and a,
they have a hit song called welcome to
DC that I saw on the video channel.
And it plays all the time,
like in the,
in the Redskins,
uh,
you know,
with the redskins play and with the
Washington Wizards play,
he's dope.
And so,
and he just went viral for marrying his
wife.
Uh,
like he proposed to his girlfriend and
they're married to the same day.
My job,
I you say,
Dang,
that just happened to went viral stuff.
Oh Nah.
And so,
um,
but this is how we get,
like I remember he knocked on my door
and I'm a mom answered it and he was
like,
how are you doing?
My name is boo.
He said,
um,
my mother wanted know if you got a cup
of milk we could borrow.
And my mom was like,
okay,
yeah,
we got a cup of milk.
My mom went to get some milk and she
goes,
this is my son.
Oh.
And I go,
Hey,
I go,
why they call you boo?
He said,
cause they said when I was born I was so
black.
Then I looked like the sound that goes
makes,
so that was his name.
Boom.
So then my mom gives him a cup of milk
and then he walked back carefully with
it for 15 minutes later.
How are you doing Ms. Smith?
Um,
I'm,
I have one now.
If you got,
um,
I have a cup of sugar she could borrow.
Yeah.
Gotta have company came back.
How you doing Ms. Smith?
My up 15 minutes later.
How are you doing Ms. Smith?
Mama know if you got one eight she could
bow you showing you all need to,
not just one eggs my mom gave him.
I'm going to give you two just in case.
So in any left came back.
How you doing Ms. Smith?
[inaudible] know if you've got a quarter
cup of or she could Jesus real talk my
mom,
give him a couple of or comes back 15
minutes later.
No.
How are you doing Ms. Smith Mama window
if you want to come over for pancakes.
He was afraid.
He was became my best friend.
Like just,
just like that.
And my mind was like,
does she needs therapy?
And you can hear his mom go,
I had that.
Oh that's fun.
And that's how we met.
And that was kind of like indicative of
the apartment complex.
Like looking back at it,
it was like basically all single moms in
that apartment.
Ah.
And so all raising young boys and we
would all go outside and play and give
each other bad information and
that's why to finger pop girls or
whatever,
whatever it tried to do,
back flip,
whatever it was.
And um,
and so that was a,
it was a,
just a great time in my life because I
was born in The Bahamas and then when my
mom left my dad at nine months,
she moved to DC for like a year and then
the pembrook apartments.
So I was in pembrook apartments from
there until like 13 or 14 so why would
you start doing comedy?
I started doing comedy in Maryland,
man at the greenbelt comedy connection
outside was a huge picture of Martin
Lawrence and Dave Chappelle was just
bubbling,
starting to like pop.
And I actually saw Chappelle bomb in
there and it isn't all of this is a
negative story.
It was fantastic how it happened.
He went up and he was doing this stuff
and it was a black crowd at the time,
you know,
he was young man.
We were the same age.
So at the time we were both 19 and he
was like,
just trying to figure it out.
And I thought he was great,
but somebody was like,
boom.
And they just thought it just the
collective bulger's like,
fuck yeah,
I'm going to be famous.
Like he literally was saying it.
Then he walked off stage and he sat
right next to where I was and you know,
that just bomb energy.
He was just like anyone looking nobody.
And I was just like,
man,
I never seen anything like that happen.
And this guy named Tony Woods went up.
I know Tony [inaudible].
They,
uh,
and so then woodsy goes up and was,
he goes,
man,
that was great standing ovation.
Right.
Then they walk off,
they walk out together getting the same
car and drive off.
I was like,
oh my God.
That was incredible.
Like just seeing that happen.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
and then,
and that,
and that's,
I started in that environment where I
learned how to perform first.
Right.
I had no substance.
I just knew how to,
I was trying not to get boots,
so I wasn't talking about shit.
I was just,
man,
you just a very active,
just an entertaining,
uh,
performer.
But everyone in that environment was so
nurturing.
Like when you got offstage,
other comments like,
you know what,
I was funny,
first slow down,
say this,
you know,
and it was like a,
it was like a weird,
I don't know,
I never had like other like black men be
vat,
like excited about something that wasn't
sports or women,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and beat that encouraging like,
yeah,
man,
you funny to Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And so I was like,
I'm home.
This is,
you know,
and uh,
it was a guy I went to eighth grade
with,
cat named Mike Brooks.
He's like the mayor of DC comedy wise.
He had been doing it a year longer than
me and took me around all the spots.
So my goal that summer was to just get
paid cause I believe that you got paid.
I'm a professional.
So at the end of the summer,
this guy named pops gave me a crumpled
up $25 to perform in front of like six
people in this big place in the
Greenville,
the comedy connection of Laurel.
And uh,
after that you couldn't tell me nothing
because we had performed in,
uh,
it's a lot of spots called cabarets
where the audience is not facing you.
So you're on stage and they're at long
tables eating crabs and stuff and they,
after Corinne and next bat.
Oh yeah.
And if I would get like a laugh or
something,
I was like,
oh,
okay,
I'm doing it.
And um,
we would,
we would do crazy stuff,
like a headline.
It would like go short and we would go
up after a headliner and eat it because
he just had him,
he was the headliner,
but for some reason he had a issue and
we would go up next.
I heard a headline to do that.
Burt Christ was telling me about that
where he would go on after the
headliner.
Yeah.
Cause the headline,
I didn't want to do the drop check spot.
Yup.
So he would,
he would go up,
someone would go up and do like 10
minutes.
Yeah.
The headline and we go up do an hour and
then Bert would go up and close the
show.
Yeah.
Mike Brooks was amazing.
Like kind of shit.
Is that,
I know.
Yeah.
We one time,
this is when,
this is when I took another suite,
Dell,
it was a,
as that same summer,
we were at one spot and they might say,
hey man,
uh,
this,
go to,
uh,
go to comedy connection in law.
Chris Thomas coming down earlier,
something.
We going to go and close it.
And I was like,
all right,
I didn't know if you weren't supposed to
do that.
And I'd get up there.
Chris Thomas Killing,
he was,
uh,
he was the mayor of rap city used to do
this move and he does like a lot of
impressions and he was,
he was,
the crowd is literally like crying.
I'm still,
I'm a go.
I'm think I'm going to kill it.
I don't know what's about to happen.
And Mike,
uh,
I went and I had to go first.
That was the other thing.
He set me up like,
yeah,
you go up,
get,
I'm gonna go up.
So I basically had to take like what was
coming.
So Chris leaves and it was no ill will
to none.
He literally had to go do something and
they introduced me.
I come out there,
this one I used to wear slacks and shirt
was tucked in.
I just smelled like a college kid.
Like I was saying,
what's up y'all?
What's up?
All right bye.
He's like,
and the checks are dropping.
I didn't understand what that was.
People are looking at their bill man
power rangers,
a crazy life.
Ah,
eight like I'm talking about sweat,
you know,
to flush all terrible,
terrible.
I'll raise offstage and then,
um,
I don't think I got booed,
but it was just silence.
It was just no labs.
And then,
uh,
but Mike,
he used to do this trick where he would
pat his intro with Shitty,
never did you see them on the Martin
Lawrence show.
You see them opening fussin bird,
you seen him on def jam,
you see,
I was like,
you ain't doing all that.
And he was like,
you gotta figure to you Megan Jordan.
And then he went out and he did okay.
And then I just learned a lot of lessons
in that era,
you know,
like kind of keep going like gift the
shit ain't working,
you know,
just keep going.
And uh,
I really had so much confidence because
I feel like that area with some of the,
some of the toughest environments to get
labs.
So when I went,
then I went to the Midwest,
I went to school at Notre Dame.
I was like,
this shit.
Like I'm,
people are friendly.
Yeah,
he's just going to be so easy to make,
you know,
to be.
And so I started a comedy or funny bone
opened up in south bend and I became
like the House Mc there and I would
watch the national headlines come
through and that helps right?
Tremendously.
And that's when I learned substance.
Like I was saying,
okay,
I gotta,
I gotta have something to say.
Isn't it interesting too,
when you would,
if you would work at a place like that,
I remembered how it wasn't Boston when I
was first starting out.
If I was lucky,
I get it
like a hosting gig and I would go get
you to see the quality of some people's
material versus others.
You would see a guy coming in as a
headline and you're like,
hey,
this is a headliner.
It was just like barely adequate.
Yes.
And you'd watch them all weekend and
you're like,
this is a whack show.
And then the next week it'd be Bill
Hicks or something and you go,
Oh fuck yeah.
Next level.
It's like,
oh Jesus.
Like you realize like it's the quality
of your thinking.
Yes.
That'd be like peop people or chime.
They're,
they're,
they're tuning in to what you're saying
and some sort of a weird way that hasn't
totally been defined yet.
You know?
And when someone is up there and they
just got some great material,
they've got great shit.
It's like he puts a smile on your face,
like it gets your brain lights up.
Like,
ah,
I like where he's going with,
yes,
I love that.
I love,
I was like,
oh,
I didn't know you could do that.
What kind of did that with the iphone?
It is,
it is like a,
it sets a personal thing for me.
Like when I see somebody abusing it,
I do get it.
Like,
ugh.
But now that I'm a little older,
I just go out.
I,
it doesn't affect me like it used to.
I used to be like,
I know what you mean.
Yeah.
When I first out I would get offended.
Angry.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm like,
Eh,
well whatever.
Yeah.
I think it's just,
we realize like what's a waste of
energy?
Like it's good to use.
Use that on yourself.
Like to look at your own material and
go,
oh,
why the fuck am I doing this?
I fix this.
Right.
That's going to benefit you.
But doing it to other people,
it's just a waste
waste.
But yeah,
I spent some of my early twenties doing,
they're like,
oh yeah.
Like I was telling you before we
started,
um,
when you talk about Australia,
Franklin,
that Dji was cause I used to,
he said he lived there for a while.
He lived there and I asked him,
I go,
why did you move to Australia?
He said,
no guns,
no gangs,
no god.
That's what he said.
Oh Wow.
But he said the money wasn't,
um,
on part of what it could be making back
in the states.
So that's why he came back.
How long did he live there?
For?
Several years.
But I,
I don't,
there was this,
that he was there.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I remember I saw him in America.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then he just went over there and,
um,
but I remember the first comedy album I
heard of his is a picture of him.
Like,
I can't think of what the name of it is,
but I'm listening to it because I used
to,
I was in like Oklahoma.
I can't remember the other comic I was
with and I at that time I used to go to
flea markets to buy albums and we
listened to it at his spot and we smoked
some weed and we were listening to it
and I was like,
he's high.
Like you can tell he's high on this
album.
I was like,
wow,
I didn't know you
do that.
Like
not
that comedian.
Seriously.
Yeah,
this dude.
But he was,
he was the first
a comedian,
the one,
the one up there with the shirt off.
That's the album we listened to.
That album right there.
Yeah.
Dope fry your hair.
It's funny man.
Smoked dope.
Fry your hair.
What a strange name is.
Yeah,
but you could tell he was high when he
was a funny dude.
Funny Dude.
I remember that they did about the
Olympics.
He was on like one of those was a young
comedian specials.
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
Did that take it goes watching Olympics.
Watching the dude comes in last,
I don't,
I train for this.
And he goes and then reality starts to
set it.
Man,
I don't even have a fucking job.
How could it not trained?
Still came in last tastic he's
fantastic,
but he was the first black
comedian I heard who didn't grow up.
Uh,
it's,
it's stick wasn't,
I grew up poor.
Right.
He was like middle class.
He went to law school and he just talked
about,
I go,
Oh,
you can talk about that.
Because a lot of,
when I first started,
a lot of comedians taking the stage,
they all felt like they had to fit into
this.
It was a thing that just happened.
But then when we talked to him offstage,
it's like way more interest in off state
march.
You talk about that,
right?
Do you think it was because they felt
like they had to fit the mold of the
popular comedians?
People wanted a certain kind of comedian
and they felt like,
oh,
I got to talk about the shit that people
want to,
how you make
it?
I think so.
And then if you,
if you stay in it long enough,
you start to just go because for a time
I had an act for a black room and then
act for white room and it just got
exhausting.
I used to be physical and I was like,
ah
man,
I don't even stay in here and talk to
these people.
Like you just kind of become what you,
you know already where that's why those
people that work,
those alt rooms getting real trouble
when it comes to a real comedy club.
You will see that.
Yeah,
man,
it's fantastic.
I've seen some people in alt rooms go to
the store and fall.
Joey Diaz and it is horrendous.
It's horrendous because they're just
used to like witty references and clever
subject manner is yes and comedy.
It's so supportive.
Very supportive,
which is nice.
It's a nice to have that,
but it,
but there are also like timid audiences
too,
right?
Like you're Joey Diaz went there.
They'd be,
they'd be like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
Why are you bringing the outside world?
Yeah,
we like our little bubble.
But,
uh,
I,
I w they had all seen man,
I liked the fact that they were like,
I can't get any heat over here so I'm
gonna go create this over here.
Yeah.
But once it started like taking off,
I did.
I didn't like the day where it became a,
it was us against them.
Yeah.
It was like,
Yo,
we all try.
Yeah.
There was a lot of shitting on people
that try too hard.
I was like,
what's he's acting out things and moving
around.
Oh,
you mean he's been a joke,
right.
It was pretty funny.
Like you don't want that.
I get it.
That's kind of what people like people
get weird about like what they're doing.
Like you should only do what I'm doing.
That's,
that's more like we're talking to,
it's a waste of energy.
It's a waste of energy.
Why?
Why,
why do you
care?
Did you were talking about Tony Woods,
Tony Woods.
I know you met Tony Way back in New York
in [inaudible] 92 or some shit like
that.
He was fucking funny,
man.
I still is.
I'm sure he has,
but there's a few dudes like him and
even Franklin,
I like most people don't know who
Franklin Jaya is.
Like how does that Carla,
how about,
how'd that guy not like who takes off
and who doesn't?
How does that work?
I'm trying to figure it out.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know his whole story,
man.
Um,
I know for
a lot of Comedians who are mad funny.
Usually marriage or divorce is where
they get some,
they divorce usually like it's like,
oh yeah,
I'll be away.
Yeah.
Well they just someone who's fucking
some other dude,
you've got to keep sending you check.
You got,
Oh,
you get to see your,
your ex wife and your,
you pick up your kids.
Kids.
Like mom says you're a loser.
Why?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
It says you ruined everything.
Yeah.
Mom says you can't pay your bills.
What?
Mom says you need to get a regular job
and stop chasing your dream.
What yet?
Oh,
that's it right there.
The Voice of fuck you up.
I think if you married the right person,
you can,
it can make you better.
Like,
yeah,
that's what's happening with me,
my wife.
I like my wife.
Yeah.
That's a nice thing.
It's important.
Yeah.
I like mine too.
Yeah,
I think that helps.
It did.
It definitely can make you like more
stable,
more comfortable,
and you learn more about yourself when
you're like totally intimate with a
person.
Yeah.
Man.
You know somebody really knows you.
Yeah.
I want to thank you for the compliment.
You gave me somebody.
I had my wife listen to it first because
someone said I did you mention me and
I'm always nervous when I,
I don't know,
my wife's a baby,
listen to it.
So he listened to it and I was like,
oh,
that's dope.
And I said,
Oh,
I said,
your top 20 baby and my wife,
you knew that already.
You are?
I said,
I think you're one of the top.
Are you guys in the world?
Really?
Doing that makes me feel good.
That makes it,
it's so funny,
man.
So many I'm doing,
I'm going to be doing like some,
some things that I've always wanted to
do years ago,
but I didn't know to ask for it.
Right.
That was the thing.
I always thought that people see your
work and then hey,
but what happened with you?
I think,
cause you started working as a writer.
Yeah.
That's when they,
yeah,
they give you a job and then you think
like this is what I do now.
But that job there's,
there's uh,
there's no free ride.
Like to get that money for that job is
nice and it gives you stability,
but it takes away from the potential
earning of your standup.
And then the dude that you started out
with,
they're balling out of control.
They're selling out places and people
don't know who you are.
And that to me,
it's crazy when I see you on stage,
I'm like,
this guy is a world class headline.
Like everybody should know when Smith.
Yeah.
You know?
And so it just drives me nuts,
man.
Working on,
and I've been trying with Ian Edwards to
exact stories.
You same exact story.
Yeah.
I remember when he had long dreads.
Yes,
I remember that dreads.
I love history.
Here's what I was just describing.
His is documented on camera.
Like Ian used to yell at the audience,
you know what was his bid on Deb?
Sam about,
he used to be mad at 80 and Tisa and
like
that's how they get you like he used to
be like yelling and then Bob not falling
for it.
Like he was like,
oh.
And then when he cut his dreads he was
like more centered,
more zen.
Just standing there talking.
I was like,
well then he became Vegan and now he
falls asleep constantly.
She has no,
no dizzy.
When I get on the plane with him,
I'll just take pictures of him.
I have like 10 pictures on my phone of
Ian out cold.
He gets US plane.
As soon as he sits down ugly,
like instantly I'm like,
I got this motherfucker face and take
pictures of us and Larry and then I send
them to him and with a bunch of z's on
it.
That's funny.
But that's,
I do that too though,
man.
I trained myself to sleep on the plane.
Yeah.
It's just kind of a thing,
like when I'm old
and I just make myself go sleep,
I don't know where I got it from.
It's a good move.
Yeah,
definitely make flying easier if you can
get really comfortable with just falling
on,
you know,
like especially those six hour across
the country,
fides conk out.
Wake up.
You feel refreshed.
Yeah.
I'm about to take the first,
ah,
my son now that he can walk now so I
won't be able to sleep.
I know he's going to be that kid.
Oh,
he's going for sure.
Yeah.
Run up and down the isles getting mad if
you try to hold onto him.
Kind of look forward to it though.
But I'm like,
ah.
Yeah.
It's sad when they get a earaches and
they start crying and you can't do
anything about them.
I mean,
you can't help them.
You can't,
there's nothing you could tell him.
Give him some time to think to chew
helps.
Okay,
that's good to know.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sometimes like,
like gummy bears or something that they
have to chew.
It will help pop their ears open.
I got my kid,
these,
uh,
vitamin gummy bears and gummy bears,
but there they are.
They're made out of essential fatty
acids.
They have vitamins in them.
And could you chew it?
I said,
don't shoot shit right now.
He everything,
look,
you got to it,
man.
Come on one at a time.
14 months old man.
They don't know anything yet in this.
Fascinating,
you know,
it's like this,
um,
you know,
you learn a lot about yourself,
man.
I'm telling you that you learned that
year enough.
Yeah,
it was the biggest lesson.
It's like I'm enough.
I walk in the door and say,
hey,
you know,
yeah,
I don't have to put on a shelf on,
like my wife says when he hears my
voice,
he lights up.
Like if I call them.
Awesome.
And so,
yeah,
I just like talking to them sometimes
when I,
when I first had him and see,
I didn't know what to say to him.
So I would just do old hip hop lyrics to
say,
this kid,
I'm just wrapping stuff.
Who the hell is this?
[inaudible] 46 in the morning,
crack of dawn and know him,
your honor.
And then he'd be like,
I know what to say there man.
And then I just started,
I would talk to him about my day
sometimes.
And it's cool man.
It's a very weird feeling.
We see a little tiny human being that's
dependent upon you.
It changes your perception of the world.
Everything.
And it's also like all of us were that
age.
So it's kind of weird when I look at
adults,
I'm like,
man,
you were 14 months.
I talk about that all time that I look
at people,
it's grown up babies now.
I used to look at people in a static
state,
like I'd see it year old dude,
that's an 80 year old dude.
That's how he is.
How he's always been.
No,
he was a baby.
Yes.
And he became this guy.
Yeah.
And he had dreams and he trashed it.
And did it work?
Yeah.
I'm fascinated by people's stories,
like shattered dreams and people with
failed expectations.
There's some of the saddest people
you'll ever get to meet if they just,
for whatever reason,
it didn't work.
They didn't figure it out,
whatever mental block,
whatever the problem was,
they just never figured it out.
Yeah,
and that's when no charlatans sneak in
that pretend to be able to sell them.
Oh,
you gotta do is what you got to do is
push harder.
You got to dream big,
and you got to set your goals.
What's an easy workshop that we're going
to have?
John hit $1,300.
We're going to have a workshop and talk
about it.
I'm going to get out there.
I don't want to clap.
We're all going to join along.
Clap together.
We're going to walk on coals.
Hot coals barefoot.
Ah,
yes.
That's how they get you,
man.
Yeah.
The motivational speaking,
uh,
marketplace is a saturated cess pool of
most people in it.
Having Accomplished Jack Shit.
Yeah.
Most of them.
Their accomplishment is that their
motivational speakers.
Yeah.
I know a comedian who was a terrible
can.
I know who you're thinking of doing it
now.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Yes.
That's how that Shit,
mother Fucker,
and when you meet him,
when you see him out,
he's always flinchy a little bit.
Yeah.
You know he's fancy like,
like a dude with a sad for him
family.
So flinchy Oh we had a side family.
Okay,
I get it.
Oh Man.
That's a lot of pressure.
Yeah,
it's a lot of pressure.
I know that cat.
Good luck man.
I hope it works out.
Yeah,
it was a lot of those guys off there and
listen to this crowd.
I would like to say I'm might have
be responsible a little bit and this is
very,
this is,
I'm literally,
this may not be true.
Okay.
We did a show together a long time ago
and it was a college kid in the college
gigs.
They make you both doing our right.
They don't know how to just go,
hey man,
you do have.
Right.
And so he was harder as far as credits
cause he had,
you know,
comedy central,
love this guy.
And they were like,
um,
so he would,
they would like a own,
you go first and I could see in his eyes
definitely.
I was like,
it was like one of those quiet things
where I go,
you know how you go,
Oh,
I'm going to do,
I'm gonna.
Yeah.
Because sometimes if it's somebody you
like,
you'll do all right.
And then they'd come.
I was like,
let me go ahead and just show this dude.
Like what this could really be,
man.
I'm telling you,
clap,
look dude,
look,
clack glass
58 minute free.
And Emma,
thank you.
Good night.
Just left,
you know,
game of game,
a great intro or whatever.
Like I saw him reevaluate and I think,
I feel like at that moment he was like,
yeah,
just gotta be another method.
Yeah.
He probably had like another two year
run,
like,
you know,
but that,
I was at a Vegan restaurant that I eat
out occasionally.
This dude was in there with all of these
people that he works with.
They meet together in this restaurant.
Yeah.
I saw him at a raw food spot before he
came up to me when I was with my
daughter once and he's like,
I just love to talk to you about a
transformative experience that I've had.
I really would love to get on your
podcast,
Mike,
the fuck out of here,
man.
It's so funny.
Mason kit is it transformative
experience?
Okay,
I believe you.
Yeah man.
Hey Man.
You know,
good luck.
Keep people,
people doing things.
People are doing things,
but there's a real problem with people
that are just motivators.
Yeah.
That's all they're doing.
All you're doing is motivated and
there's a lot of,
man,
there's a lot
of them.
I'm always getting these fucking memes
from people.
I'm like,
who's this guy?
Then I'll go to this page.
It's all filled with memes and then you
know,
like you'll look at it,
they're like,
he's a motivational speaker.
Oh,
you're a motivational speaker.
Well,
what have you done?
Had He,
it's weird to be a motivational speaker
who's never done a one thing.
Like you have to start a company,
come up something or life coaches.
Same kind of thing.
Yeah.
But the weird thing is some of them,
like there are trainers that have never
had professional fights and they're
great trainers.
Okay,
but they have studied the game like so
deeply.
They understand all the various aspects
of the game,
right?
And then they become just really good at
it.
I'm really good at coaching because they
were like real legitimate analysts.
Is that possible to do with life?
Can you be a person who has never really
accomplished much in term nothing
creatively,
nothing.
Nothing.
Like you're not some world champion
dude.
You're not some guy who's gone out there
and accomplish great things.
You're not like Sebastian younger award
journalists.
You're not.
You're just some guy who's like,
well,
you got to do is realize that you face
fear in the eyes.
You tell fear.
I think that's the nature of your soul.
It's the approach man.
It's like they have,
you can't tell people what they have to
do,
but I feel like you like,
so I feel like you're a bigger motivator
than a motivational speaker because you
motivate by example,
but you just motivated by doing you.
You see what I'm saying?
Like,
that's more motivational than
telling people,
I'm going to tell you how I do what I
do.
It's like I don't want to,
I just,
Oh,
Joe did that.
that's dope.
Then you know what I mean?
So you just go,
oh,
okay,
Joe comes from comedy.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
All right.
If he did,
I let me,
what am I not doing?
You know what I mean?
Like to me that's more motivational
then.
That's how I feel coming to my front
door.
And uh,
you know what I mean?
But you know,
when people are always looking for some
sort of a s of course shortcut,
you know,
like someone is going to end.
Sometimes people can give you like I
have like these I had yesterday on the
podcast,
but he's a six time world champion power
lifter and you know,
when he talks about hard work and
dedication and you know,
like fuck your excuses.
Like you're like,
okay,
fuck my excuses.
Like it makes sense right now.
Like you believe him.
But I think there's a lot of people out
there that want to be that guy,
but they don't want to do that kind of
work.
They don't want to accomplish some great
task before they go out and do this.
All this motivational stuff,
right.
They want to,
you know,
personal,
they want that and hippie pussy.
That's what they,
that's what they,
that's what they want.
That's what a lot of it is.
You want those girls who are trying to
improve themselves.
I'm just trying to be more spiritual.
Me Too.
Vulnerable.
It's not just vulnerable.
It's seeking,
seeking like yoga girls,
dude,
yoga girls.
There are so many freaks in,
in the yoga community.
You know,
so funny.
I'm so,
uh,
above board.
Like I've gone,
I go to yoga and I do my,
my thing and then I'll,
I'll look,
but I'm like,
I don't even know how to make this my
spot.
You know what I mean?
Like something,
some guys,
yeah,
let's go to yoga.
Like they,
they know,
cause I heard one of my yoga teachers
hit on a student in middle line was so
lane.
He said,
um,
I feel like I've practiced.
Um,
what did he say?
What was what,
what are you always trying to reach?
Um,
and Yoga,
whatever that shit is.
I feel like I've practiced something,
something,
something with you before.
And she goes,
yeah,
it does feel like that.
It was
terrible.
They started talking,
he had his hair and shit and I was like,
there it is.
That's,
I could never,
that's not my thing,
man.
But yeah,
Yoga is when people are talking about
the practice and they say,
that was an amazing practice.
I can't talk to you.
Yes.
I feel like I've practiced.
I forgot what he said.
I just want it to,
but I'm not a cock block,
but I just thought it was something like
that.
Something out on a mat before it's done.
Yes.
Sonia's.
Oh yeah.
What is it?
I wasn't,
what's the word?
It just taking the class.
I don't know.
Yeah,
man.
You know?
Yeah.
It did this thing.
How often do you go?
Once a day.
Once a week thing.
Yeah.
I try to keep it no more than,
well,
no less than once a week.
But I've fucked up since I did a sober
October.
We had 15 classes that we had to do in a
month.
Did I tell you about this?
Me,
Thompson Guerra,
Bert Kreischer and Ari Shaffir.
We made an agreement.
No Pot,
no booze,
15 hot yoga classes,
90 minute hot yoga classes in a month.
It was rough,
but it broke me.
It broke me in terms of my enthusiasm
for yoga.
I like enough because what really broke
me was not just a 15 classes.
I could've done that,
but I did nine in a row to end it.
I just said I had some days after that
too that I could get it,
but I was like,
no,
I'm going to burn this shit out.
I'm just going to bang it out.
Nine or I was going Saturday,
Sunday,
Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
But it,
when it was on it,
when it was over,
it felt good.
Yeah.
I feel good.
Right?
I did it.
What I'm Russell Simmons gave me a month
free at his Tantra Yoga spot when he
went.
He does tantric yoga,
Tantra,
Tantra.
It's that,
what's the difference?
I could tantric cause what you're
holding your comeback,
right?
Squeeze it.
Not your last longer just due to do that
all day.
They just
ease their,
their Dick Muscle it.
That's like the weakest muscle I have in
my body.
You know,
if you think about if he's thinking,
if you just squeeze,
hold the comeback muscle,
like use that right now.
Just try to slow it down right now.
Right now ready to go.
Does that feel so spongy and weak?
Like if I have to squeeze my arms like
my choke muscles like Oh yeah you could
do that.
Choke the fuck out of somebody right
now.
But like chuck my own Dick with my
dinner,
with my air ticket muscles like nothing.
It's like I'm saying tires a week,
Eh Jesus.
Those muscles have zero conditioning.
I remember somebody told me,
you know how you do dumb shit?
Like,
I don't know if you ever did this,
but somebody told me if you press on
that area like really hard for a couple
of seconds that it won't do it right
that you won't come.
And I tried that shit before.
Didn't work.
Garden Hose,
you get a bear in a gardener,
right?
It came out basically choking out your
deck.
You choking it out.
You gotta just get a gable grip and go
down there.
Andrew Mash the base.
Your Dick.
Like I just,
I just come and apologize.
It's like,
Hey,
I got what I wanted.
I'm sorry.
Give me 20 minutes.
Well we were reading about mail key
goals once.
Oh,
like a mail key goals.
And I'm like,
listen dude,
I don't care what anybody says.
This is the tighten up your butthole,
but sex.
But they're not talking about that.
They're like sort of dancing around
that.
Like all the benefits of mail.
Key goals.
Like you can control your bowels better.
We control your total status.
Right?
What do you mean better?
Like who silo.
I mean it's one thing he got diarrhea,
but right.
Regular control of the bowels is pretty
much 100% it's out.
It's coming out.
I know what I'm doing.
Oh Man.
Oh,
you know,
it was crazy.
So that's fine.
This is nasty,
but
it's,
I'm only child,
right?
So growing up like,
shit,
what happened to me?
And I would just be like,
what the fuck is that?
So when I take like really good shit's
like,
I cry like,
so
this is when it worked in my advantage,
my son something,
he was doing something and me and my
wife couldn't figure it out.
And then there's one tier was I go,
I always taking a shit.
He gets that from me.
Like it was accurate.
He had to shit and it's for something
was going on.
And so then we helped them and adjusting
them and I,
my wife,
if she watched you watched it,
she'll find out about this.
He does not know that about me just now
what?
I know.
She knows.
That's how I was able to crack that
mystery because everything is a mystery.
And I go,
what's he doing?
He was just sitting there,
but he had this look on his face
came.
I'm like,
Oh,
I just pass that on.
that's so crazy.
What a random level
random thing,
man.
Like it's so crazy.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno man.
That's so strange.
Yeah,
it's so crazy,
man.
It's weird how though the body work,
like sometimes I'll just be driving down
the street and a tear rolled down my
cheek.
I was like,
I'm not even sad.
Yeah.
I'm not happy.
I'm not selling.
Why am I crying?
Sometimes it's just leaking.
Right.
It's amazing.
May you know what else?
My Body,
if I'm in a room and I'm supposed to be
awake,
you ever get like sleepy?
Sometimes if I get sleepy,
my Dick will get home
around that area.
Well sometimes I'll be in writer's rooms
that I get sleepy and my and start
getting like,
oh fuck.
So then I'll try to go to the bathroom
to throw board on my face.
But now I'm slightly like a wreck
getting up.
So making sure nobody's looking at me.
Right.
Like some freak.
Yeah.
So I'm like always in there.
Always pull my shit down.
But it's not funny.
You get an erection.
Everybody knows you get erection.
Yeah.
Right.
If they get an erection near them,
like what the fuck?
I know I had a boner.
Sorry.
It's human nature,
but you can't,
especially in mixed company.
Yeah,
yeah.
Especially today.
Nah,
you can't day half the day,
man.
Just think about all the sexual
harassment that people just sort of like
that was there the way they behaved.
Yeah.
The office,
that was their thing.
And now you see now you can't do that.
Why they went to the office,
like they couldn't wait to get to work
to
chase whomever was there,
pinch the secretary and the blood.
I mean it's,
you know,
my mom had a thing like that when I was
a kid.
I didn't understand it,
but somebody was,
you know,
she needed the job.
So what I will say to,
you know,
um,
women watching what my mom did and she
just kept elaborate notes so that,
cause she knew it was gonna be his word
against hers.
And you know,
predators don't keep notes,
man.
They don't keep notes.
So right.
Mom was like October 8th Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
They,
you know,
she was protected and so,
wow.
It's just don't try to go off memory
like that,
you know,
even if you're keep notes,
man,
still you against them.
Yeah,
it still is.
But back then boss,
whoa.
But still once you,
cause that's how,
who I think,
who had somebody else had no,
the Weinstein thing.
Somebody kept like notes and that's why,
I mean,
cause you,
when you have a lot of money you can
definitely litigate it.
Like I'm a sue under the right.
But when somebody,
you know,
and I think his legal team looked at it,
they were like,
you better go to Europe for some deep
counseling cause however they,
you know,
Europe counseling and a different level.
That's the,
I believe the continent.
Right,
right.
My head on straight,
I'm gonna stay over here.
Yeah.
It's to be able to do that.
It's crazy.
Well like
you look at like the Kevin Spacey thing,
like that's how he would run a set.
Apparently he'd be on the set and he'd
just be grabbing dicks on the set.
Serious.
Yeah.
That's what they're all saying.
I mean,
I don't know if that's the truth,
but all the people in the House of card
set,
this is what all the complaints are
coming out was that he would like grab
guys dicks that we're taking them places
and he'd have like a PA that had to take
him somewhere.
He reached in his pants and grabbed his
dick.
He was just a dick.
Dick crab grabbed um,
whose dick was it that he grabbed like
some famous dude,
uh,
Richard Dreyfus.
He grabbed his son's Dick and him in the
room.
Ah,
he was just a crazy Dick grabber stop
maniac.
Crazy drunk Dick grabbing,
ah,
the reservation.
And I think this is their social
environment as well as their working
environment,
right?
They're constantly around all these
people and they're,
they're in this king roll.
Yay.
Like if you're a star of a show that
you're the executive producer of and
it's a giant hit for Netflix and you're
the king.
I'm Frank Underwood,
the king of House of cards and all the
people rely on you for their jobs.
This is one of the things they're saying
about house of cards is that 2000 people
could be out of a job.
Exactly.
Which is crazy.
So this guy was like at the epicenter,
like he was the p the king of 2000
people.
So he would show up at work and his ego.
I'm the king,
you know.
And I think that is like natural male
predatory behavior when um,
I think when a man gets into a position
where he's the king and all these people
Cya,
maybe we get you something sire.
Like if you're on a set and you're like
the big star,
all these people are stumbling around
sire.
Maybe,
maybe we get you something sire.
Like you start thinking like a king.
Like if you're Harvey Weinstein,
like think about all the people that
covered up for him.
He had it written in his contract was
crazy.
I mean,
but also just think of that work ethic
man.
Like,
you know what I mean?
He like just to work that hard.
And then the part that trips me out is
when people would show up to the victims
ago,
tell me everything to me.
We're going to,
we're going to take him down.
And then those people were investigators
and they go,
I work for Weinstein,
bitch.
Like you better not,
you know how fucked up that it has to
have you walking around in the world.
But they're predators,
man.
And they'd look for like,
you know,
it's this weird shit,
but it's like if you,
you know,
they had like a parent or somebody
going,
baby do you think is safe to,
you know,
meet with him at three in the morning.
And they were like,
mama is cool.
It's going to be fine.
Trust me.
Why don't you trust me?
You know?
And then when something happens,
they feel like they can't say anything
because they don't want the,
I told you so they don't want to,
oh,
well,
whatever it is.
And then that,
that moment can turn into two weeks and
I saying that you had six month,
then you're living,
you know what I mean?
And,
and so that's how it can happen when
you're just so embarrassed.
You know what I mean?
Or you don't want to embarrass or hurt
other people at times.
Sometimes people don't say anything
because they don't want to make their
parents feel what type of way,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a lot on a lot of women that had
been rape victims that the,
the stigma of being a rape victim,
excuse me,
publicly,
is it's so hard.
It's so terrifying on tariffs.
They don't even,
they're like,
I'll just let it slide and it's,
it's like man,
it's horrible.
Yes.
I mean,
so I'm personally,
I'm happy that people are finally
speaking,
you know,
coming out.
Cause it's,
it's,
it's a lot of jobs opening up.
I'm really happy that people are finding
that courage to just,
you know,
speak that truth and we'll see what
happens on the other side of it.
Will we be a healthier society saying
this for a while that I think that
eventually we're going to get to a point
where we could read each other's minds.
I really think that that's on the,
on the horizon.
I think it's just a matter of time
before no one can ever do anything like
that ever again.
And I think that's what you're seeing
now with like this Harvey Weinstein Shit
and the Kevin Spacey Shit and all this
other stuff.
I mean you see varying degrees of it.
Some of them seem pretty innocuous.
Like Al Franken just likes to grab butts
when he takes a picture.
It's like not the best practice,
not the worst thing in the world,
but I think we're going to get to a
point where all of this is look back on
like wearing powdered wigs or slavery or
any crazy old shit that we just don't
tolerate it anymore.
Just nutty behavior that you just can't
do anymore.
I think we're going to get to a point
where you're going to be able to talk to
someone and you're going to be able to
see what's going on in their head and
you,
you would have to be a real piece of
shit to victimize them cause you're
going to get to see what their exact
feelings.
Oh you just need this job.
You're not really attracted to me.
You don't like me at all,
like you just need this job,
but you might have let me jerk off on
you if you could keep this job because
it's gross.
I gotta stop.
You know?
It was interesting too.
I think that this is a direct reaction
to us not communicating with one
another.
You know what I mean?
It's a day like today,
like everything is texts.
Like put my boys in a single day,
you know,
they getting girls to texts like have
you talked to her yet?
But she's sending me like all this.
So you're not really,
yeah.
And I think can be taken out of context,
what have you before.
But yeah,
it is getting to the place where you're
going to have to be really clear with
your intentions.
Like I'm married to see it.
You can be able to see tensions on
people.
Oh Wow.
You know another thing I think that is
ridiculous,
and I'm not pro prostitution,
but I think it should be legal.
And I think if it was legal you would
have way less of this gone.
Oh yeah.
Wait.
Hello?
Yeah.
Cause that's what it is,
right?
It's just that release and people need
to craziness.
It's forbidden.
Shit.
There's a lot,
there's a lot of factors going on,
but I think one of the things that would
change is that people that want like
ugly dudes like Harvey Weinstein,
it just want sex and here you're going
to just go get it.
But I think for him it's like a power
thing too definite.
I mean,
he was banging all those really hot like
famous chicks.
And this drug dealer told me a long time
ago,
it was two things he was talking about,
man,
it says two things,
understand ass whooping or a secret.
And if you came with they ass,
you better get a secret.
So,
and that's,
uh,
you know,
I feel like Harvey doing that shit to a
lot of people because they became huge
stars,
right?
There's no reason for them to ever have
to respect him again.
You know what I mean?
But he was like,
yeah,
but you,
you know,
with this is,
take my whatever,
whatever his,
well that would,
apparently he,
he wouldn't negotiate it into deals.
He would say,
if you fuck me,
you'll get more lines.
You'll get part to get this.
You get that.
And so it's like,
I mean,
but that is like my main,
he was like,
so what,
when do you know your worth?
Right.
And when you know,
well,
the view,
you know what I mean?
I'm good.
I don't need this here over here.
Or I've already,
the work I've already done like my,
my last work paid for all this shit.
Right.
Where are you getting your money?
You're getting your money from something
I did.
You know what I mean?
Like instead of thinking about it like,
Oh,
you can give me more money.
It's like you sitting on this,
you got this sweet from my performance.
You know what I mean?
Like,
right.
This dude wrote,
you didn't do shit.
Yeah.
He literally came up with this guy wrote
this guy shot it.
Yeah.
You Ain't,
that's what's interesting.
He's like,
he's not the creative guy.
I don't know.
No,
it's just the money guy that fucks the
women.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird,
man.
It's weird how long you got away with it
for it.
For decade after decade after decade.
It's,
it's,
it's crazy man.
It's almost like the,
like every person that you look at me
like,
Oh man,
that person doesn't know.
What shocked me the most about Matt
Lauer.
That motherfucker was making $20
million.
25 I heard it was 2,500 2028
and they had to pay him.
They had to pay him to pay him out.
Last contract,
they said I was just reading,
they don't know if it's going to be
finished through is 2018 contract,
but he also was getting flown a
helicopter rides too,
is like a Hampton's house so he could
spend more time with his family or
something in between.
Damn Matt Lauer things.
Well,
what happened?
All of them call us cats.
Get paid out though.
What's the Charlie rose get when he had
to step out?
Did he get paid out?
But he was on pbs.
It probably wasn't getting paid.
Riley got a lot of extra money,
right?
Riley paid 30 $35 million in a sexual
harassment settlement.
Like what the fuck could you have
possibly done?
Just think about it.
Faculty like,
okay,
if I give you 35 million,
you shut the fuck up.
Like 5 million is j Lo House.
Hold up though,
Joe,
this is fucked up.
But that victim should be a motivational
speaker
that vic motivates to talk to other
victims that I had.
It was,
hey,
first thing I did was I limped around.
I pretended I couldn't walk good.
And
I always get nervous.
I'd have to sit down 35 I put the
vulnerable.
It worked out.
Yeah,
I mean,
I wonder what he did.
it was just one.
I mean another one,
I think he paid 12 there was like
several different ones that he had to
pay off.
Like this guy was on a rampage for years
and years.
Yeah,
he's a trick man.
He was on the streets.
He's a trick that pays well.
He's a house money.
35,000,035 come on man.
And everybody already knows you're a
freak.
So it's like you wasted 35 million.
Like everybody knows you're a freak.
Yeah.
And so who do we,
where do you start?
Like is it the platform who,
who gave them the platform and that guy,
you know,
I think it's a bunch of things,
but one of the things that I think it is
is that that world
is so sexually charged.
All the men are like these powerful
wealthy men and all the women are hot as
fuck and the off short skirts on and
they're all talking about like,
like American values and it's all
conservative values.
That's all super,
super breast behind closed doors as
button popping and fucking
trading,
snoring,
Pussy,
lips,
Woo.
Maca
being a policy.
That's what's so puritanical too though,
man.
You know,
they don't teach,
they don't teach six education
to younger kids is never cool to talk
about this shit.
So there's definitely that.
But it's also the suppression,
the ones that are like super religious,
super suppressed.
Like those are the ones that have this,
they have a need for an outlet.
Of course.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I feel like it's,
it's equal.
Right.
So the amount that you put out,
you equally have,
right.
You know what I mean?
Like that.
Who was that guy to the senator or
congressman with the fuck or was it just
got busted like,
uh,
having,
he was an anti gay Oh,
Yay.
And he turns out he was,
he got busted having sex with a dude in
his office.
Inappropriate behavior and they called
it.
Yeah.
And they had is very convenient and it
give them the ex,
he is anti Lgbtq lawmaker resigns over
gay sex scandal.
Republican state,
Ohio state representative.
Lastly.
Oh,
Wesley Wesley.
Good man.
He may have also previously assaulted an
18 year old.
Uh hmm.
Hey assaulted.
Is it like Kevin Spacey type of salt?
Like Dick grabbing,
no to word assaulted some weird Straw
man.
Words are violent.
Oh No.
Your words are violence in touch.
You No,
no,
no.
Your words are violence.
Okay.
That's what comedy's had it.
Yeah.
I feel uncomfortable.
I know there's certain,
there's certain taboos now that he just
breaching them on stage.
You see people say,
well,
you know,
yeah,
I wish they did that.
Like with comedy tickets,
like I understand when you buy a
baseball ticket,
the back is like an agreement that if
you get hit with the ball,
you ain't going to lie.
Is that when it is you,
you agree that if,
if some debris hit you,
hey man,
it's a part of the experience and uh,
they needed a little comedy.
Clubs like feelings get hurt,
like you've already agreed to
experience.
Yup.
You know,
a performance,
you know what it's going to affect it.
I don't know how it's going to land when
you,
but when I think it was really a report
on it or you got a band,
people that interrupt like,
especially like bad hecklers and
interrupt hecklers sometimes man can,
like,
you're,
you're setting up like for a special,
you getting ready.
They can fuck up the flow of a boat for
weeks all ways.
And they,
it seemed like,
it seems like they always come out when
you're setting up for something of card.
Right.
And then you just,
you just rocking.
Yeah.
Perfect.
I gotta,
I gotta lay down.
He had a comb in the moral arbiters of
what you're allowed to say and not say.
It's like,
you don't even understand where this is
going.
Like you're not even allowing this bit
to take its full.
I get to the end,
it'll be vindicated.
Just let it play out and play out.
Trust me in the end,
I'm the piece of shit.
Just trust me.
Trust me.
Everyone wins.
Yeah.
But that's a weird thing about live
performance.
That's what makes it so exciting.
Yes.
You are there to catch debris.
Occasionally it will be a tire will fall
off one of them nascar things and
launching a crowd.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's uh,
I don't know,
man.
You got to keep swinging that bat
though.
You've got to keep pushing it.
Yeah.
Well then also the real terrifying thing
for me is the throwing away the material
and then redoing your whole act every
two years.
Oh yeah.
That's the real terrifying thing.
It's really about,
for me,
it's about a year and a half,
it seems like lately that's my schedule.
And at a year and a half.
It's like,
yeah,
like right now I'm super nervous cause
I'm like a couple months out and then
once I film I'm fucked up.
I just figured out how to make these
bits all work good.
I know.
And it's exciting,
right?
It's like I could grab this for five
years now,
but I think it's healthier though.
Oh it's way healthier.
But it is like,
but what you're talking about too is
something that I've gone through.
It's like the older you get,
the less you,
the less you have.
Your faith isn't as strong.
Like when you're younger you gotta I
know him to come with one boy.
Shit,
something's gonna Happen to me.
I'm thinking my faith is better now than
it was before.
I work harder at it now.
Yeah.
It's like to me it's the,
it's directly proportional.
Like how much time I'm actually spend
writing and working on new shit and
trying out new shit versus like whether
or not a thing I could do it again.
You know like if,
if,
as long as you're paying attention,
there's always subject.
I feel like subjects too are essentially
like scaffolding.
Yes.
And once you have the scaffolding,
then you've got to fill it up with jokes
and build us the phone part two and
then,
yeah,
I like,
I love the work man and it's so like I'm
at a place why I love it even more now
than when I first started.
You know what I mean?
Like it was just a blind love for it,
just how it made me feel.
But now I've really light getting in
there and trying to like take it places
and it's so exciting to me,
man.
It's like I'm so,
I feel so present and awake,
you know what I mean?
Like when I'm on stage and I just,
I'm excited about it.
But it is true though.
Like,
um,
if I wished that this was all I could
focus on,
you know what I mean?
Right.
Visiting my family,
that's all I want to do is stand up and
family.
It's one of the reasons why it is so
exciting is because it's just slightly
out of your reach.
It's obviously within your reach.
Talent wise.
Yeah.
Just like you still have this writing
job,
there's still good.
Yeah.
It's the reason why I never intended it
to be a TV writer.
Um,
I didn't even know that was a job,
you know,
I mean like I
went one day on the set,
uh,
a friend of mine,
he was a comic and then became show
runner of everybody hates Chris.
And he uh,
called me out the blue and said,
hey man,
you want to come read lines with Chris?
And I was like,
yeah.
So I went on set in,
the job was to be his voice because it
was a voiceover show.
Everybody's going.
So I was his voice for the actors for
the pacing.
So I'd be off on the side.
My mother always said like I was just be
reading it and uh,
then I was like,
oh this is cool.
This is,
I was like,
this is like the best acting class cause
I'm seeing,
cause at the time I was also like acting
classes and doing all of that.
Oh Shit.
I'm seeing what it's like on set,
how to act,
because I will watch costars come in and
just rumble because it's not acting.
It's not a save acne class.
Like when you're acting on set,
there's a,
it was a boom.
Got It.
Don't give a fuck.
I roll it up.
Cable.
This guy,
he was saying,
yeah,
you have to like,
you know how to find it in these raw
environments.
So I used to watch that and,
but because I'm a comedian first,
when they would run lines,
I would hear stuff that could be funny
and I would just write it on my script,
but I wouldn't say anything.
I knew better than trying to say
something.
And then one day show runner,
his name's Ali,
he goes,
uh,
amen,
the CNA work and you got anything?
And I was like,
do I?
Yeah.
Uh,
you should say this.
It was just,
I just wanted to make it better.
And then,
uh,
he laughed and then he threw the London
and she laughed and then they did it and
the whole crew laugh and then they
recorded it and I was like,
oh,
that's cool.
What?
I didn't even think like,
oh that was great.
I was just like,
yeah,
that's what it should have been in like,
right.
And then,
um,
Chris rock came up and he was like,
fuck that.
You say this and change it.
And they laugh.
Then I was like,
I got another one.
And that was the first time I'd ever
seen Chris like in person this day.
I go,
I got another one,
I give it to them,
they throw it in and they laugh louder
cause it was like you say this gave him,
they laugh and not as loud.
Didn't know.
I probably should have shut up.
I had another one cause I was like,
if I,
if Chris or like me,
this would be great,
you know,
that kind of shit.
Right.
I was like,
this one,
they laugh,
they do it,
they laugh loud.
Chris goes,
I got nothing.
I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
and so then at the end everyone's in
line shaking Chris's hand.
When I shake his hand,
he puts his,
uh,
like does the elbow thing.
He goes,
what's up Nigga?
I'm like,
Chris Rock called me nigger.
He like,
I was so happy I playing and did like a
college gig or whatever and came back
again.
And so then that,
that grew into me doing what they call a
punch of writing.
But I didn't need,
I didn't know it.
I didn't know.
I just,
I enjoyed helping them make the show
funnier because that's like my,
like if I hear something,
oh that's dope.
Go for,
you know,
that's kind of always been my nature.
And I had this older,
one time,
this older black dude was at the store
and he said,
stop helping other people get better.
Keep that shit for yourself and Hossein.
Alright,
who said that?
I can't remember,
but he just,
it's like he came out the shadows and
just said it to me because what counts?
We get off stage.
I'd be like,
Oh man,
you should do this and that.
And then I would go do my work.
I like,
I'm the,
I'm not doing that.
So,
um,
but whatever you're doing,
I go,
I could hear it.
Oh man,
maybe go here.
That'd be dope.
Some people will listen in and some
people have amazing careers.
And some people were like,
all right.
And then I started figuring out,
oh,
they don't want me to say nothing.
I ain't gonna say nothing.
And then I did eventually just stop
saying stuff like that.
She's just kinda just to kind folds
away.
But I used to be,
I was like,
uh,
I used to just love hearing what people
were trying to do and then go,
hey man,
I wasn't,
someone on the outside can see it better
than you can.
And I wasn't annoying.
Like I wasn't like,
but I haven't like,
aw man,
that thing,
maybe this.
And if they laughed it was cool and I
literally didn't think about it again.
Like I wouldn't even remember then.
Uh,
so that evolved into me.
Like they used to let me rewrite scenes
on set because I was just,
the way this particular show runner
work,
his whole philosophy was funniest wins.
And you know,
if you got it,
you got it.
And then,
uh,
so he would bring stuff in from the
writer's room,
which I was rarely in,
cause I wasn't a writer at that time.
And then when they would put it on its
feet,
we could hear how certain people
couldn't say they was,
they would sound funny,
you're saying a different word or maybe
it should just take a different turn.
And we were kind of on the same,
so he would let me rewrite.
And uh,
that grew into,
then I found out about writing and like
there's a writer's guild and you know
all this stuff.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'll do it.
I like to see what it's about.
Why not?
But I didn't get a writer's job until
years later,
but I had,
I had went through a bad breakup here
and I wanted to go to New York.
You know what,
I'm breaking it to me.
You want to change zip code.
So I tried to,
I was so naive.
I go,
I'm gonna write on Conan.
So I started like sending,
because this is when he was in New York.
I didn't hear anything.
I ended up having to be here for like
another two years.
And then after I gave up that dream of
wanting to just get a writing job in New
York so I could live in New York,
I ended up getting a writing job in
Stanford,
Connecticut.
And I took it.
It was my first writer's guild job,
but I moved to Harlem.
And so I will work on set all day and
then race down to the cellar and perform
at the cellar.
So wow.
I was living a life that I always wanted
to do at 20,
but I was afraid to move to New York,
uh,
at 20 cause I didn't think I could
afford it for some reason.
I'm,
so I lived in Chicago and then I moved
to La.
For some reason I felt like I could do
those towns.
But um,
so I was living in Harlem when I was a
comedian and I would write there in the
day.
It didn't,
I didn't even like think of it as a
thing.
And then that grew into,
oh,
I'm,
I'm pretty good at this.
I know what this should look like.
I don't know how to tell a story.
I know,
you know what I mean?
And then she start coming around the
store.
I came around the store on everybody and
it's crisp.
I came out the first in the 90s.
Wow.
Spring break.
1990 for me,
uh,
sunny,
I can't think of her last name,
but she's the one with the view now.
Uh,
the,
the um,
she's one of the ladies on the view.
Sorry.
Uh,
we were all in,
we all went to Notre Dame.
She went to Notre Dame law school.
Um,
me,
my boy floyd,
he pretended to be my manager.
We were all in this,
we all did display raisin in the sun.
And then for spring break we all came
out together and I went to all the
comedy clubs because I was doing comedy
at Notre Dame and he pretended to be my
manager and I got up on like some,
some black rooms I got to do stand up
there and we went to all the comedy
clubs and everybody was nice too.
It's like I'm a comedian,
visited from the Midwest.
Can I just check out the room?
Yeah,
come on in.
I went to the laugh factory.
Oh,
this is shiny as fuck.
Okay.
This is cool.
Nice,
Nice.
Went to the Improv.
They let me in.
Okay,
cool.
Come to the comedy store.
A dude named Chewie is stamina and I go,
hey man.
And some people,
he was so intimidating.
He made me lose the bass in my voice.
I was like,
hey man,
I want to just go in.
And he was like,
do you know how many motherfuckers say
they a comedian?
And like he chewed me out and it scared
me from the store and I was,
I was like,
Yo,
like everybody else was showing such
that I was not expecting it and I was
just like,
who is this dude?
I don't want to get nick out.
Damn.
So I stayed away from the store.
She scared me off.
Scared me off.
Like so much science guy once you get to
know him.
Yeah,
but so much so like almost I before I
put like a vendetta and my head against
this deal,
but like it's hilarious.
The student traffic,
you know,
how strong you are,
close you out on the street.
Like I was really like angry
and I just walked away and I was like,
fuck this guy,
fuck this place.
And then,
um,
I uh,
didn't move out until 2000.
Right.
And uh,
I was doing a lot of commercials in
Chicago.
Right.
And I booked 10 national commercials for
blockbuster music or something.
It was me and this dude named jt Jaggedy
Ilc,
I think his name is,
he is one of the sonics guys though.
Sonics bits of sonics commercials.
Okay.
He's one of those guys and we did 10 of
them.
I was getting paid twice because they
were using my hands too.
It was like a video game spot.
So my was a hand model getting paid and
then my face was imposed on one of my
thumbs in his was on other than what he
did.
And so I thought I was going to make a
lot of,
uh,
and they were supposed to air during the
superbowl 2000 super vote.
And then I booked and then I did radio
to promote a show and they offered me
the guide.
The program director liked my voice and
on me a radio gig.
He was like,
Yo,
you want to do the morning radio here?
And I t I did a test run for like a
couple of weeks and it did really well.
Not a no way.
I get a call from Don Buchwald uh,
how it's,
don't know if he's still Howard
surrounds agent when he was like,
oh in Don Buchwald we know,
let me negotiate your deal.
I was like,
all right.
And so we figured you were going to be a
big time morning Dj,
Dj guy and I did not want to be a local
celebrity at all.
Like I had known I want to go to bed at
eight o'clock gig too.
I know and wake up at four in the
instance what I did,
I did that for two weeks and my body
felt paralyzed but my numbers were
really good apparently.
Cause you had to meet with this dude
named Gebo something and he was like,
oh and your numbers are great.
Just don't say this word so much that I
was like,
Ugh,
I was,
I was already like,
ugh.
So then this guy calls me and I go,
all right man.
I said I want 250,000 and he was like
Ha,
and this is right when I think clear
channel,
somebody was buying up all the radio
stations.
So base salary was maybe 60 something
like that.
And I was like,
I ain't going.
So I just said,
I was like,
cause I had these commercials coming.
So I go on with 250,000 he was like,
all right,
let me see what I could do.
So I was supposed to come out here for y
two K I suppose to come out here before
the ball dropped,
you know,
1999 right.
But I had to stay an extra like six
weeks,
maybe four weeks while they negotiate.
So every,
like every Friday dan would call me
owning.
We got it up to one 20 nope.
Arrogant,
26 year old eight.
I love it all.
When we got it up to one 80,
nope,
I've never met this man.
I do.
My wasn't know him if he passed me in
the street.
Wow.
When we got it up to two 20 with your
remote,
your make your to 50,
where you just take the Gig?
No one,
no one has ever gotten this before.
Nope.
I got my
flip phone at the time.
And you have a razor phone?
Yeah,
some dumb flip.
Some stupid ended.
I hung it up and uh,
he was like,
all right,
I think and maybe,
but he was like,
alright,
you're good luck,
you know,
hung up like that.
And anyway,
I wasn't like a
radio GIG plus remote.
You would have made a quarter million
dollars in 1990,
1999 smell way.
And it was a,
it was already knew yet cause I drove
out here and my 1991 gray Honda accord,
uh,
drove through the southern route from
Chicago and stopped at Grand Canyon.
Yeah.
Or Denise,
I'm going to be famous,
famous.
I'm gonna make it all that shit
out before then.
And the copyright.
Yeah,
it's from,
because there was a Viacom's spot from
the 10 national commercials that I did
called me and said,
hey man,
we got some bad news.
There was an in house legal dispute and
fire kind of between your spots and the
spots called thumb wars.
And so we're not,
there's ED already so we're not going to
be airing your spots,
but um,
we already,
we already edited a fuse,
we'll send them to you.
Oh.
So I had like,
I just had the session fee.
So the commercial money I was banking on
and nothing be,
so I went from thinking I was going to
at least have,
you know,
super bowls,
10 national spots,
right.
And doing a superbowl ad.
That time when commercials actually
paid,
I was counting pre counting money and
uh,
I thought I was going to lead to make a
quarter of a million that year at least.
And then,
uh,
nothing.
And so then I ended up sleeping on my
boys air mattress,
a preacher moss.
Shout out to preach.
Did you ever think about calling them
back with the Radio Gig?
No.
Wow.
I'm no good for you.
Never.
I never,
yeah,
it was like,
I was like,
I didn't want to be a local,
I was,
my,
my reasoning was if you're offering me a
radio Gig at 26,
I can get a radio gig at 56.
It's a voice.
You know what I mean?
That was my thinking at the time,
my 26 year old thinking and then,
um,
so no,
cause I,
I didn't want to go back.
I felt like I had done everything I
could do in Chicago because like,
when shows were coming,
I would get like a coaster on it.
So I was like,
I want dude's that tried to make it out
of like those local mark.
Like remember man cow.
Yeah.
In the morning,
get mad cow in the morning.
He was a Chicago Guy,
wasn't he?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then him and Howard stern of the
crazy beef went after him.
Yeah.
Howard stern lapped him.
He was like a guy who was like a Chicago
guy that was sort of bleeding out into
other markets and then it all went away.
Yup.
So when I came out,
I was sleeping on an air mattress,
got some pussy on it strong.
It was consensual and sex on an air
mattress.
And the girl likes you that much.
Pretty good.
Yeah.
It's like almost like futon sex.
Fantastic.
But yeah,
it was,
I told her I was,
I was funny,
I was like,
is like a poor man's waterbed and he's
not crazy,
you know,
whatever.
But uh,
I was there for 18 months,
man,
and I would drive up and go to acting
class and acting class and crazy fucking
people in acting class.
Oh my God.
Yeah man.
But it was,
it was great.
It was a great time,
right.
To just really like learn the art form
and a different level and then just see
who's out here.
But I didn't fuck with the store.
I was,
I would drive past it and not,
I was doing the Improv,
you know,
once every two months and like just like
coffee houses and stuff.
And then,
um,
it wasn't until I was when everybody
hates Chris and Chris Rock was doing,
uh,
that special way he performed in South
Africa and he was working on that and he
just said,
I'm going to the store tonight.
I was like,
Yo,
I want to come see it in.
I just come.
I was like,
cool.
So I sat in the Olr and I watched Chris
go up and at that time I was,
I wasn't in,
I've still not at the laugh factory,
but I did the Improv and I would do the
laugh factory on like chocolate Sundays
or whatever.
But the Improv,
it felt like you had to have your set
already worked out.
Like you couldn't fuck around,
couldn't fuck around the or and you
couldn't really go outside the box of
what a comedian is.
And so when I was at the store,
I saw a few comments go up before Chris
and I was like,
Oh shit,
you can be an artist here.
Like that was my first instinct.
Like you can do whatever you think is
your thing here.
And then I saw Chris go up and I was
like,
I have to get in here.
Like it was,
I was like,
I got whatever I got,
I got to do it.
I got to get him.
He wasn't around,
he wasn't around and I saw it.
So then check this out.
Uh,
so then I started coming down on Sunday
and Monday and Tommy was doing it at the
time and I would listen to Tomi talk and
stuff.
And what blew me away about Tommy was I
never met a person who ran a comedy club
who knew that much about comedians.
And who was that passionate about
comedy?
Like I didn't,
I didn't know him from anything.
I just,
I just never,
all the funny bones that I had to work,
nobody gave a fuck about the lineups and
kind of like his process.
So I didn't mind him talking to me.
I was like,
Oh,
this guy likes to talk.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
A lot of people probably don't talk to
them.
And so then when he would talk to me
about comedy,
I was blown away by the hits that he
knew a specific history of it.
And Yeah,
you didn't get a chance to see him
emerge as a crazy fuck.
He became,
no,
no.
So then,
so,
uh,
he would give me two minutes,
the two minute spots,
you know,
it's two minute spots and I would do too
many things.
And then he,
he was like,
ah,
I'm going to give you 10 minutes.
And then he goes,
uh,
I'm gonna give you a showcase for Mitzi.
And he would call me.
It's going down now and I would drive,
get all,
it just is not happening.
I'll go back home because the,
he was still sexy with six was Belson
come in.
She was still doing auditions then.
Huh?
I don't know.
I'm bad with that.
Um,
but the class that I was in with visible
as a Glickman,
Steve Glickman,
me and Steve for past the same year,
so maybe 2000,
well,
the Chris rock thing was 2007.
So then after I left,
I left the store 2007.
Yup.
So it was all right,
right on the heels of that,
right on the heels.
And then,
uh,
so maybe I got passed in 2008 maybe.
But,
uh,
do you work?
Do you work like comedy and Magic Club?
Yeah,
that's a great,
I love it man.
I'm going down there this weekend.
Hopefully you really hope for them,
although the national improv's and
stuff.
No,
no,
no.
I used,
when I was a road comic,
I used to,
like Dave stroop used to book me in
Columbus and Columbus and he used to pay
me at four feet.
Trekkies pay me well,
and then he would code feature me Cole.
And then he just stopped bugging me.
I tell you,
I can tell you a story.
I don't care.
Um,
he,
there was this waitress that work there
and I fucked her
and I fucked her all weekend,
but I didn't approach it like she came
on to me.
Right.
And if the waitress,
I don't know,
but I'm going to say when they've paid
me,
he goes out of the blue,
he goes,
did you fuck so and so?
And I W I was like,
Nah.
And uh,
and then he was like,
okay.
And then,
um,
he's never booked me since that,
but I didn't want her to know if I
would've gotten in trouble.
What kind of a weird question is Adam
and I,
and again,
dude,
this comes from like,
maybe not growing up with a dad.
I would have known how to handle that
better.
But like if,
if my,
if my dad,
if I have some knowledge from that,
but I,
I just was like,
I'm not going to get her for,
I'm leaving like I,
so I'm not going to be like,
yeah,
fuck.
Like I was like,
Nah,
I didn't know his fucking business.
I didn't know what to do with case.
If he's the boss,
he's the boss.
Are you a private contractor?
You kind of a private contract.
Do you come in and it's not like you're
getting health and dental from him now,
but the whole thing was really your
boss.
But it's his club.
Yeah.
I used to work.
I don't know.
I mean,
I was never told you couldn't write.
You know what I mean?
But it's always been the case.
Guys have always done it.
Only one club,
they said,
don't do it.
We're in La.
It was a milwaukee,
the comedy cafe.
I used to do that room.
I get how they would see it was gross
comedians hitting on the waitresses all
the time.
But I wouldn't never had a job.
I would always do my,
you know,
my energy man,
I would perform and I would sit down if
they came over until I would talk,
you know what I mean?
But I was never like,
I'm not growing.
I'm not opposed to face him on deals
came onto me and it was,
it was,
it was rent.
Like I wrote a show about this,
like me and this other dude.
We know like you,
you like we,
if you're throwing the pussy at us,
we won't pick it up.
Like you have to literally be like,
will you?
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
I'm,
when I'm there to do comedy,
I'm not conflict.
This is where I eat.
You know what I mean?
So I'm not thinking of work.
I mean,
I might see I'm,
I'm definitely gonna see you got damn,
you look good,
but I'm not going to,
I'm not going to change up.
You know what I mean?
So she had,
I forget,
I don't even know how it happened.
It was like,
um,
I think she asked me if he wanted to get
something,
eat to eat afterwards and we got
something to eat and we were just
talking and I was like,
Oh shit,
she's flirting.
Oh,
that's cool.
But we were away from the club,
what's up?
And then she made,
I need to come back to the condo.
It was like a weird,
I was so goofy.
Like,
all right.
And then,
Oh shit,
we fucking,
and then,
but it was literally,
no,
I was no game want me that she just
picked me.
I wasn't a lot of that weekend.
Like whoever she was mad at before,
she was like,
this dude,
I want that.
And that's really how that went down is
it wasn't a me thinking about it.
You know what I mean?
Like that's a funny thing because the
digger,
you're kind of working together.
Yeah.
When people in bars,
they always wind up hooking up.
Like that's like the constant thing in
bars,
bartenders and the waitresses.
Pj always doing that.
I really man,
like,
I mean,
I would say in my twenties I was more
like conscious,
you know,
I knew how to like,
I could change my act to get an audience
member or whatever.
Like,
all right,
she's cute.
Let me talk about this topic.
She'll come up.
That was so crazy,
you know?
And then I would know how to
do all that stuff or go to the mall and
invite somebody,
you know that.
Right.
But then as I got older,
I think I wasn't concentrating your
comedy.
Yeah.
I was like,
at this date,
Sam was so valuable to me and I was just
like,
really?
I just wanted to just,
and then I was trying to figure it out
because it was at that time,
like later on it was about DVD sales.
Like we hear Comedians,
I sell out every time.
I'm like,
I sell two dvds at.
So then I started going,
what am I not doing?
So then I,
I would fix that and then it would be
like lines waiting for my DVD.
But I'm a horrible salesman.
So one person want to get in the
conversation for a long time.
I don't want to be nice.
And then you just fucked up my line.
Like you talk too long,
you know?
So I had to learn how to like,
keep it moving,
you know what I mean?
And then I,
then I didn't really like talking to the
audience that much afterwards,
something if I'm doing like racial stuff
because it would always come back.
Ah,
I used to do this joke about how,
um,
uh,
Busta rhymes,
I went to a buster,
Ron's concert and he,
he uh,
and it was all white and he had an real
niggas make some noise and everybody was
like,
ah,
so the punchline,
it's like white people are niggas now.
And I was like,
ah,
oh did I say and not only can we call
him Nigga,
they are paying $85 for the privilege to
be called native.
Right.
And uh,
so then my job would be like white
people.
I call you Nigga for $10,000 Nigga cell
Nigga clearance cash only.
Cause I know how you niggas and all like
that was like a joke I would do on the
road.
And then I would be out selling my DVD
and always,
you know,
a drug white person will come up and
give me $20 ago,
Nigga,
oh call you nick.
And I'm like,
ah,
fuck.
That's a problem.
When you get forbid and words for the
bitten words,
man,
don't wait to blurt them out.
Can't wait.
So we used to,
we used to joke like,
what if that was my thing.
Like what if,
what if I didn't sell product?
And I was like,
y'all could just call me Nigga at the
back for $20 and like just shake up the
whole t shirt DVD selling thing.
Like who is this guy letting white
people calling me,
you know,
it just,
it would it be,
got it got so,
you know,
it's that growth process.
Every comedian,
every,
I think minority comedian wants to
figure out race like in their twenties
and early thirties they want to fix it
or have some clever angle to no one's
done before.
But the reaction to that is you do,
you do.
And I'll give you work in Kentucky at
the late show Friday and you're here,
you come talking about,
you know,
a black man invented the golf tee
because he was tired of holding the
ball.
Like they're like,
what?
You know what I mean?
It's like a different,
you got to figuring it out,
you know?
And so now it's funny when I hear like
younger comics,
you know,
attack and race and in that familiar
place it's like,
yeah,
that's cool.
But uh,
what's like,
what's,
what's beyond that,
you know what I mean?
But it's also like you're dealing with
talking to the audience and the problem
with talking to the audiences,
you might run into seven people that are
really cool and great to talk to you
like,
man,
I'm glad I met you.
And then you run into two drunk morons
that your entire night
and then you're like,
I can't even believe I have to talk to
you.
Yeah.
And I'm stuck talking to you and your,
you know,
the problem is you think you can make
fun of why people and why people can't
say the n word to you like you think you
think that's okay.
You could say it to us.
We count cheese compensation,
which is draining.
I can't do this.
Yeah.
It was like when you did,
you can't pick who your meeting after
those shows,
especially if you're trying to sell
something.
So that was like,
I just don't want to have to sell
something.
I just want to put too much work.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
I'll talk to you after this cause I,
I did what you paid for it.
That's right.
I used to take march with me.
I did it a few times on the road.
It is grueling.
Grueling.
I can't do it.
Kim Can't be,
you get on a plane with so much promise.
If I say,
well at least I know due to its shit.
Their shit ahead.
Do it.
Ship boxes ahead.
Tape everything down.
Yeah.
And you'd hear about Gabriel,
Gabriel Iglesias,
he's selling $1 million but a tee shirts
like watch.
I know.
Wow.
What's he doing?
He's got a warehouse filled with tee
shirts.
Like what?
Yeah,
I'm not fat.
I'm fluffy,
but he's killing it.
Yeah.
It's an interesting world.
The world of like trying to figure out
what your thing is,
you know?
Yeah.
But for you,
we just got to let people know.
Just come see me.
Yeah.
You just gotta be headlining on the
road.
I'd go put out special.
Any approach to you?
It's about,
about a special,
no,
the two that I've done,
I've done out of pocket and I got
stories about that.
I did one in 2007 I made a lot of money
doing colleges.
Um,
cause I really,
I was like I can make some money and
quick hits and I figured out what my ask
was for the college market and I
finally,
my agents would never put me in Naca
nationals.
They would always do Naca regionals and
Naca is the National Association of
campus activities where you know,
you,
you get submitted and is in college,
you know.
Yeah,
I did all that.
yeah,
yeah.
So,
but I knew I,
and I never,
I rarely or never got selected to
regional because my humor works best if
people,
if everybody can see it at that time,
like when I was talking about,
so if I did something,
someone from the south to be like,
that's too,
but someone from up north,
man,
shut up.
That's dope.
You know what I mean?
So I,
I said nationals would be my spot.
They finally put me in.
I get picked.
I get to do it.
And I had,
and this is right when Kobe got accused
and stuff,
and I had this Cobi joke that I did and
my agents were like,
keep it clean.
And I was like,
man,
I'm doing this my way.
I'm listening to you all these years.
And so,
and I and I knew what the kids want it.
Like I knew what the students want it
once I get,
once you get to that school with the act
that people think they have to do to get
the job,
it's your act.
Just do that.
So I did my act,
uh,
duties,
these coby jokes in the middle and it,
it changed the chemistry of the room,
you know what I mean?
Because everyone was coming out,
you know,
doing the safe stuff.
And then the colby joke that I told was
a colby,
I paid $30 million to drink sprite,
$30 million,
just the drinks,
sprite.
I go for $30 million.
I would drink my own.
Come I say it is on a knack of thing.
Right?
I know,
I know women who have done it for far
less.
That's the joke,
right?
Right.
Pace goes crazy.
I get offstage,
my agent is red,
but there's a line around the corner at
my booth because I was the only guy that
talked about something that was
happening like right then and I had a a
thing on it,
get over like 120 schools and I,
and I did that burn every,
you know,
you know what that is.
So you saying that you made about of
money and then you put together a
special,
we have made a bunch of money put
together a special called anonymous shot
in south bend,
Indiana because I was in these writers'
rooms when people are going to midwest
doesn't get it,
the midwest doesn't get it.
And I was like,
I want to show them that the mini
Wisconsin hired uh,
everybody,
right.
I'm the director.
I want it.
Couldn't do it.
Referred another director.
I had already purchased the place and
air time and all that stuff and I had
people from,
everybody hates Chris.
They were going to do favors for me.
So my budget was at,
say it was at like $40,000.
Right?
Then I had to hire this other guy and he
said,
I don't like working with people.
I don't know.
You got to hire all my people,
doubles my budget.
We took a scouting trip,
uh,
met his DP.
They had my act.
They knew all my moves.
Like I had this down cold,
Terry Cruz.
Cruz flew in and introduced me.
And when we get on the plane to fly,
the director says the DPS not going to
make it.
He,
I found out later he took another gig.
So now I'm performing my special that
I'm spending now $100,000 on in front of
four camera guys who have never seen my
ad.
Oh No.
And I do the special and it went great.
Did two shows.
I'm still hype about it.
Get back the footage.
This guy or whatever you could.
This is the medium shot.
Soft focus.
Both shows no blurry.
So no,
all my punchlines are over my left
shoulder.
Oh.
Which is not high.
So I couldn't resell it.
So I had to put it on Youtube and my boy
calls it the most expensive demo tape
when you,
oh my God,
it's called [inaudible] Smith anonymous.
And I was so,
Yo,
I was stressed man.
I lost a patch of hair.
It was,
it was a DP and go,
what the fuck?
I never did.
Wow.
That's crazy.
I never did.
How did you not like I fucked you.
I just,
I didn't pay the director to this day.
I just didn't pay him.
I pay this crew.
I paid everybody else.
Biggest check I ever wrote at that time.
And I never,
but I would just say to him,
I said,
I'm not paying you.
I go,
you know why I'm not paying you.
And I said,
you had two shows to see this.
I could've done my whole act over
without an audience.
Like I knew it that well just to,
you know,
capture this in my whole purpose was to
resell it as you didn't listen to him.
It was this thing,
cause he had only done music.
He hadn't done comedy.
I knew every special and,
and Oh and the reason in that whole
year,
every directed,
I came and directed everybody hates
Chris episodes.
I would take them to lunch cause I,
if I found that they did come the
specials and I would pick their brain on
that.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
So I was very confident
and what I needed,
you know,
and cause didn't work.
And so,
uh,
that put me like I was scared to spend
my own money on anything else.
You had to do anything for 10 years.
And then,
uh,
the,
I've,
I then I shot a special on our iphones.
I bought 10 our phones,
we lift the place,
right.
Uh,
shot economy special.
And then I returned the I phones,
videotape myself returning the I and got
my money back and I released that
special,
we sent that to Netflix.
And at the time they,
the,
not the people who are there now,
but the people who were there before I
heard,
they just said I wasn't famous enough to
have an athlete.
There's a lot of people that aren't very
famous that have netflix specials though
that could be argued.
That could definitely be arguing and so
that was another,
you know,
so I just put that up on Youtube.
It's called good luck everybody.
Those are the two.
So those are available now.
Go watch him.
He had the one that you shot with
iphones.
Good.
Look everybody.
I just,
how much that costs to shoot it all with
iphone,
it cost me,
I paid an editor,
so
if I didn't pay him,
it would've cost me
less than a thousand dollars.
That's a great deal with the editor
calls me in the bargain.
Maybe eight grand.
Do you remember when Dave towl did
something where he gave the audience
cameras them film him?
Yeah,
it was great.
That's a smart move,
man.
If you've got something to say,
it don't matter how you had a moment is
captured.
I feel like if just saying something,
just doing something like that.
I mean,
especially Dave.
Dave is at his best.
If you've seen David tell he's at his
best in these small crowds,
small audiences,
like he was at the Improv last week.
Whoa area.
See when I'm dead last to audience is
half gone.
Everybody's tired.
But he's still hilarious.
He's fantastic man.
I used to go up after him a lot at the
cellar and it was like prairie.
It was beautiful.
Just the way he would.
Yeah man.
I love watching him work.
That's a real,
like a real master of his craft and a
real veteran.
Yeah.
Nothing's going to shake this dude and
he's got so much material always
writing.
Constantly writing chain smoking and
I know,
I know.
Yeah man.
But yeah,
so those are the two that I've done.
But Naw,
not yet.
Hopefully somebody approached me to,
cause I have some stuff that I really
would love to.
Yeah,
man,
we gotta get you out there.
We've got to get you out there.
Yeah,
I mean the store right now,
it's so crazy how many talented people
are there and man deal von Lit that
place on fire last night.
He was dope.
I want,
I don't want to tell any of his bits,
but God damn,
he had me crying.
It's like there's so many people right
now that are so good.
Weird.
It's like the level at the place.
It's like never before.
Never before.
I mean I started there in 94 and the
levels terrible.
Wow.
There's a bunch of Badass.
Yeah.
A bunch of guys from the road that like
they had started out there in the 70s
and they were still around,
but they had the same act.
I mean there was some literally some
people that start out there and like 78
and they were still floating around in
94 and they were just fucking terrible.
It was death and then somewhere around
2000 and maybe like four or five started
picking back up and it was pretty good
for a couple of years.
Then I bolted in 2007 after the Carlos
men see it thing and I didn't come back
until 2014 announced as a hot as fuck.
It's never seen it like this.
Never seen the,
the this,
this level.
There's so many funny guys around the
corner too is so inspiring,
like,
yeah,
is amazing.
And the store helped me tremendously,
especially to,
or cause,
um,
you,
you can't show him your weight through a
bit,
you know what I mean?
Like you have to know what you came to
say.
Yeah.
And I love that.
I love that.
It sounds is it challenges you as an
artist to really,
all right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Like you can't giggle and be like,
you see people try to,
and it's ugly.
It's terabytes.
It's a audience filled with comedy
nerds.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a lot.
It's a different,
it's a different place now.
Yeah.
It used to be like you'd get away with
way more there.
It's now at the level so high.
It's just,
uh,
the expectations are so high.
It's great,
man.
It's the best place to build that muscle
because then when you go anywhere else,
it's like,
I know it's running with weights on.
Yeah.
But listen,
man,
I'm glad we got you in the air.
Uh,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna see you tonight and you're
going to be on that.
Uh,
the,
the benefit that we're doing do,
what am I saying?
Justin rent.
That's December 6th.
That's sold out folks.
Yeah.
That's for the fight for the forgotten.
They build wells in the Congo and that's
going to be at the comedy store.
It'd be you and me and yeah.
Tom Segura,
Tom Papa,
Tony Hinchcliffe get it.
And Whitney,
Whitney Cummings.
Hey,
powerful.
All right.
We'll see you guys soon.
Cool.
Thank you.
Alan Smith.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Oh,
what's your twitter?
Tell people I went Smith for real.
For Real.
And instagram.
Same thing.
Thanks brother.
Thank you.